[Laughter]
[Music]
chris don how are you
good good to be here good to have you
here man um
you were just telling me before we went
on air the numbers
of the social dilemma and their bonkers
so what just say that
yeah uh the social dilemma was seen
by a 38 million households
in the first 28 days on netflix which i
think is broken records and if you
assume you know a lot of people are
seeing it with their family because
parents seeing it with their kids uh the
issues that are on teen mental health
uh so if you assume one out of ten
families saw it with a few family
members we're in the 40 to 50 million
people range which is just broken
records i think for netflix i think it
was the second most popular documentary
throughout the month of september
or film throughout the month of
september is really well done
documentary but i think it's one of
those documentaries that
affirmed a lot of people's worst
suspicions
about the dangers of social media and
then on top of that
it sort of alerted them to what they
were already
experiencing in their own personal life
and like highlighted it
yeah i think that's right i mean most
people were
aware i think it's a thing everyone's
been feeling that
the feeling you have when you use social
media isn't that this thing is just a
tool or it's on my side
it is an environment based on
manipulation as we say in the film
and that's really what's changed that
you know
i remember you know i've been working on
these issues for something like eight or
eight years or something now you please
tell people who didn't see the
documentary
what your background is and what you how
you got into it yeah so
i uh that you know the
the film goes back as a set of
technology insiders
my background was as a design ethicist
at google so i
first had a startup company that we sold
to google and i landed there through a
talent acquisition
and then um started
work about a year into being at google
made a presentation
that was about how essentially
technology was holding
the human collective psyche in its hands
that we were really controlling the
world psychology
uh because every single time people look
at their phone they are
basically experiencing thoughts and
scrolling through feeds and believing
things about
the world this has become the primary
meaning making machine for the world
and that we as google had a moral
responsibility to
uh you know hold the collective psyche
in a thoughtful ethical way and not
create
this sort of race to the bottom of the
brainstem attention economy
that we now have uh so my background was
as a
as a kid i was a magician we can get
into that i
studied at a lab at stanford called or
studied in a class called the stanford
persuasive technology
class that taught a lot of the engineers
at in silicon valley kind of how the
mind works and the co-founders of
instagram were there
and uh then later studied behavioral
economics and how the mind is sort of
influenced i went into cults and started
studying how cults work
and then arrived at google through this
lens of you know technology isn't really
just this thing that's in our hands
it's more like this manipulative
environment that is tapping into our
weaknesses everything from the slot
machine rewards to
you know the way you get tagged in a
photo and it sort of manipulates your
social validation and approval
these kinds of things when you were at
google
did they still have the don't be evil
sign up
i don't know if there's actually a
physical sign was there was never a
physical sign i thought there was
something
that they actually had i think it was
there's this guy
was it paul not paul what was his last
name he was the inventor one of the
vendors of gmail and they had a meeting
and they came up with this mantra
because they realized the power that
they had and they realized that
there was going to be a conflict of
interest between advertising on the
search results
and regular search results and so we
know that they knew that they could have
used that power and they came up with
this
mantra i think in that meeting in the
early days to don't be don't be evil
there was a time where they took that
mantra down
and i remember reading about it online
and and they took it off their page i
think
that's what it was yeah and uh when i
read that i was like that should be big
news
like there's no reason to take that down
why would you take that down
yeah why would you why would you say
well let me give you a little evil
let's not get crazy it's a good question
i mean i wonder what logic would have
you
remove a statement like that that seems
like a standard state like it's a great
statement
okay here it is google removes don't be
evil claws from its code of conduct
in 2018 yeah yeah i wonder why
did they have an explanation did it say
anything
underneath him don't be evil has been a
part of the company's corporate code of
conduct since 2000 when google
was reorganized under a new patent uh
parent company
alphabet in 2015 alphabet assumed a
slightly adjusted version of the
do the right thing do the right thing oh
that's a spikey movie [ __ ]
however google retained its original
don't be evil language until the past
several weeks
the the phrase has been deeply
incorporated into google's company
culture
so much so that a version of the phrase
has served
as the wi-fi password on the shuttles
that google uses to ferry
its employees to its mountain view
headquarters i think i remember that
yeah
get on the bus and you type in don't be
evil i wonder why they decided
well i mean they did change it to do the
right thing i mean we always used to say
that
um just to friends not within google but
just you know instead of saying
don't be evil just say let's let's do
some good here right that's nice
let's do some good years yeah think
positive think doing good
instead of don't do bad yeah but the
problem is when you say do good the
question is who's good because you live
in a morally plural society and there's
this question of who are you to say
what's good for people and it's much
easier to say let's reduce harms than it
is to say let's actually do good like
this
it says the updated version of google's
code of conduct still retains one
reference to the company's unofficial
motto
the final line of the document is still
and remember
dot dot dot don't be evil and if you see
something
that you think isn't right speak up
okay well they still have don't be evil
though so maybe it's much ado about
nothing
but uh having that
kind of power we were just before the
podcast we were watching jack dorsey
speak to
members of the senate uh in regards to
twitter censoring the hunter biden story
and censorship of conservatives but
allowing dictators to spread propaganda
dictators from other countries and
why and what what this is all about one
of the things that
uh jack dorsey has been pretty adamant
about is that
they really never saw this coming when
they started twitter yeah and they
didn't think that they were ever going
to be in this position
where they were going to be really the
arbiters of free speech for the world
right which is essentially in some ways
what they are i think it's important to
to roll back the clock for people
because it's easy to think
you know that we just sort of landed
here and that they would know that
they're going to be influencing the
global psychology but i think we should
really
reverse engineer for the audience how
did these products
work the way that they did so like let's
go back to the beginning days of twitter
i think his first tweet was something
like
checking out the buffaloes in golden
gate park in san francisco um
you know jack was fascinated by the taxi
cab dispatch system that you could send
a message and then all the taxis get it
and the idea is could we create a
dispatch system
so that i post a tweet and then suddenly
all these other people
can see it and
the the real genius of these things
was that they weren't just offering this
thing you could do they found ways of
keeping people engaged
i think this is important for people to
get that they're not competing for your
data
or for uh you know money they're
competing to keep people
using the product and so when twitter
for example invented
this persuasive feature of the number of
followers that you have
if you remember like that was a new
thing at the time right you log in and
you see your profile
here's the people who you can follow and
then here's the number of followers you
have
that created a reason for you to come
back every day to see how many followers
do i have
so that was part of this race to keep
people engaged as we talk about in the
film like these things are competing for
your attention that if you're not paying
for the product
you are the product but the thing that
is the product is your predictable
behavior you're using the product in
predictable ways
and i remember a conversation i had with
someone at facebook who was a friend of
mine
who said in a coffee shop one day people
think that
we facebook are competing with something
like twitter that
one social network is competing with
another social network but really he
said our biggest competitor is youtube
because they're not competing for social
networks they're competing for attention
and youtube
is the biggest competitor in the digital
space for attention
and that was a real light bulb moment
for me because
you you realize that as they're
designing these products
they're finding new clever ways to get
your attention that's the the real thing
that i think is different
in the film the social dilemma rather
than talking about you know censorship
and data and privacy in these themes
it's really what is the core influence
or impact that the
shape of these products have on how
we're making meaning of the world when
they're
steering our psychology do you think
that it was inevitable that someone
manipulates
the way people use these things to
gather more attention
and do you think that any of this could
have been avoided if there was
laws against that if instead of having
these
algorithms that specifically target
things that you're interested in
or things that you click on or things
that are going to make you engage more
if they just allow these things to if
someone said listen
you can have these things you can allow
people to communicate with each other
but you can't manipulate
their attention span yeah i mean i think
the
so we've always had an attention economy
right and you're competing for it right
now
um and politicians compete for it can
you vote for someone you've never paid
attention to
never heard about never heard them say
something you know outrageous
no um so there's always been an
attention economy
and so it's hard to say we should
regulate who gets attention or how but
it's
it's organic in some ways right like
this podcast is an organic
i mean if we're in competition it's
organic i just put it out there and if
you watch it you don't
or or you don't i don't you know i don't
have any say over it and i'm not
manipulating it in any way
sort of so i mean let's imagine that the
podcast apps were different
and they actually while you're watching
they had like the hearts and the stars
and the kind of voting up in numbers and
you could like send messages back and
forth and
apple podcasts worked in a way that
didn't just reward
you know the things that you clicked
follow on it actually sort of
promoted the stuff that someone said the
most outrageous thing
then you as a podcast creator have an
incentive to say the most outrageous
thing and then you arrive at the top of
the apple podcast or spot or spotify app
and and that's the thing is that we
actually are competing for attention
it felt like it was neutral and it was
relatively neutral
and to progress that story back in time
with um you know twitter competing for
attention
let's look at some other things that
they did so they also added this retweet
this instant resharing feature
right and that made it more addictive
because suddenly we're all playing the
fame lottery right like i could retweet
your stuff and then you get a bunch of
hits and then you could go
viral and you could get a lot of
attention so then instead of
um the companies competing for attention
now each of us suddenly win the fame
lottery over and over and over again
and we're we're getting attention uh and
then um
i had another example i was gonna think
about and i forgot it
what was it um you can jump if you want
um
apple has an interesting way of handling
sort of uh the way they have their
algorithm
for their podcast app is
it's secret it's kind of it's weird but
one of the things that it favors
is it favors new shows and it favors
uh engagement and new subscribers so
comments engagement and new shows
and that's the same as competing for
attention because engagement must mean
people like it
and that's yeah and there's going to be
a fallacy as we go down that road but go
on
well it's interesting because you could
say if you have a podcast
and your podcast gets like let's say a
hundred thousand downloads
a new podcast can come along and it can
get ten thousand downloads and it'll be
ahead of you in the rankings
and so you could be number three and it
could be number two
and you're like well how is that number
two and it's got
ten times less but they don't do it that
way and their logic
is they don't want the podcast world to
be dominated by
you know new york times the big ones
yeah and whatever
whatever's number one and number two and
number three forever we actually just
experienced this um
we have a podcast called urine divided
attention and since the film came out
in that first month we went from being
you know in the lower 100 or something
like that until we shot to the top
five i think we were the number one tech
podcast for a while and so we just
experienced this through the fact not
that we had the most listeners but
because
the trend was so rapid that we sort of
jumped uh to the top
i think it's wise that they do that
because eventually
it evens out over time you know you see
some people rocking to the top like oh
my god we're number three
and you're like hang on there fella just
give it a couple of weeks and then
three weeks later four weeks later now
they're number 48 and they they get
depressed
right well that was really where you
should have been but
the the thing that apple does that i
really like in that is it gives
an opportunity for these new shows to be
seen
and where they might have gotten just
stuck because these
these rankings and the ratings for a lot
of these shows
these shows are so consistent and they
have such a following already yeah it's
very difficult
for these new shows to gather attention
right and
the problem was that there were some
people that game the system
and there was companies that could
literally like earl skakel
remember earl became the number one
podcast and like
no one was listening to it earl has
money
and he he hired some people to game the
system
and he was kind of like open about it
and and laughing about now isn't he
banned from
itunes now or something i think he got
banned
because of that because it was so
obvious he game the system he had like a
thousand downloads and he was number one
i mean the thing is it were apple
podcasts you can think of as like the
federal reserve or the government of the
attention economy because they're
setting the rules by which
you win right they could have set the
rules as you said to be uh
you know who has the most listeners and
then you just keep rewarding the kings
that already exist versus who is the
most trending there's actually a story
a friend of mine told me i don't know if
it's true although it was a fairly
credible source who said he was a
meeting
with steve jobs when they were making
the first podcast app
and that they had uh made a demo
of something where you could see all the
things your friends were listening to so
just like making a news feed like we do
with facebook and twitter right
um and then he said was well why would
we do that
if something is important enough your
friend will actually just send you a
link and say you should
listen to this like why would we
automatically just promote random things
that your friends are listening to and
again this is kind of how you get back
to social media how is social media so
successful because it's so
it's much more addictive to see what
your friends are doing in a feed but it
doesn't reward what's true or what's
meaningful
and this and this is the thing that
people need to get about social media is
it's
it's really just rewarding the things
that tend to keep people back
addictively the business model is
addiction
in this race to the bottom of the brain
stem for attention well it seems like
if we in hindsight find size 20 20 what
what
should have been done or what could have
been done had we known
where this would pile out is that they
could have said you can't do that you
can't
manipulate these algorithms to make sure
that people pay more attention
and manipulate them to ensure that
people become
deeply addicted to these platforms what
you can do
is just let them openly communicate
right but it has to be organic
and then the problem is so if this is
the thing i was going to say about
twitter
is when one company does the
call it the engagement feed meaning
showing you the things that the most
people are clicking on
and retweeting trending things like that
let's imagine there's two feeds so
there's the feed
that's called the reverse chronological
feed meaning showing in order in time
you know joe rogan posted this two hours
ago but that's you know
after that you have the thing that
people posted an hour and a half ago all
the way up to
10 seconds ago that's the reverse
chronological um
they have a mode like that on twitter if
you click the sparkle icon i don't know
if you know this
it'll show you just in time here's what
people said you know sorted by recency
but then they have this other feat
called what people click on retweet et
cetera the most the people you follow
and it sorts it by what it thinks you'll
click on and want the most
which one of those is more successful at
getting your attention the sort of
recency what they posted recently versus
what they know people are clicking on
retweeting on the most certainly what
they know
people are clicking on retweeting the
most correct and so once twitter does
that
let's say facebook was sitting there
with the recency feed like just showing
you here's the people who posted
in this time order sequence they have to
also
switch to who is like the most relevant
stuff
right the most clicked retweeted the
most so this is part of this race for
attention that once one actor does
something like that
and they algorithmically you know figure
out what people what's most popular
the other companies have to follow
because otherwise they won't get the
attention so it's the same thing if
you know netflix adds the autoplay 54321
countdown to get people to watch the
next
episode that if that works at say
increasing netflix's watch time by five
percent
youtube sits there says we just shrunk
how much time people were watching
youtube because now they're watching
more netflix so we're gonna add
54321 autoplay countdown and it becomes
again this game theoretic race of who's
going to do more now
if you open up tick-tock tick-tock
doesn't even wait i don't know if you
know if
your kids use tick-tock but when you
open up the app it doesn't even
wait for you to click on something it
just actually plays the first video the
second you open it
which none of the other apps do right
and the point of that is that causes you
to enter into this engagement stream
even faster so this is this again this
race for attention produces
things that are not good for society and
even if you took the whack-a-mole
sticker you took the anti-trust case and
you
whack facebook and you got rid of
facebook or you whack google or you
whack youtube
you're just going to have more actors
flooding in doing the same thing and one
other example of this
is um uh the time it takes
to reach let's say 10 million followers
so
if you remember back in the ash wasn't
ashton kutcher who raised for the first
million followers
race with cnn right yeah so now if you
think of it the companies are competing
for our attention
if they find out that each of us
becoming a celebrity and having a
million people we get to reach
if that's the currency of the thing that
gets us to come back to get more
attention
then they're competing at who can give
us that bigger fame lottery hit faster
so let's say 2009 or 2010 when ashton
kutcher did that
it took him i don't know how long it
took months to for him to get
a million i don't remember it was it was
a little bit though right
um and then tick tock comes along and
says hey we want to give kids
the ability to hit the fame lottery and
make it big hit the jackpot
even faster we want you to go from zero
to a million followers in
10 days right and so they're competing
to make that shorter and shorter and
shorter and i know about this because
you know speaking from a silicon valley
perspective
venture capitalists fund these new
social platforms
based on how fast they can get to like
100 million users there was this famous
line that like
i forgot what it was but i think
facebook took like 10 years to get to
100 million users
instagram took you know i don't know
four years three years or something like
that
tiktok can get there even faster and so
it's shortening shortening shortening
and that's what people are are that's
what we're competing for it's like who
can win the fame lottery faster
but is a world where everyone broadcasts
to millions of people
without the responsibilities of
publishers journalists etc
does that produce an information
environment that's helped that that's
that's healthy and obviously the film
the social dilemma is really about how
it
makes the worst of us rise to the top
right so our hate our outrage our
polarization
um what we disagree about black and
white thinking more conspiracy oriented
views of the world q anon you know
facebook groups things like that
and i can we can definitely go into
there's a lot of legitimate conspiracy
theories i want to make sure i'm not
categorically dismissing stuff um but
that's really the point is that we have
landed in a world where the things that
we are paying attention to
are not necessarily the agenda of topics
that we would say
in a reflective world what we would say
is most important
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
conversation about
free will and about letting people
choose
whatever they choo whatever they enjoy
viewing and watching and paying
attention to
but when you're talking about these
incredibly
potent algorithms and the incredibly
potent
uh addictions that people
that the people develop to these these
things and we're pretending that people
should have the ability to just ignore
it and put it away
right and use your willpower yeah that
seems
i have another kids i have a folder on
my phone called
addict and it's all all caps and it's at
the end of my
all you have to scroll through all my
other apps to get to it and so if i want
to get to twitter
or instagram the problem is that the app
switcher will put it in the most recent
so once you switch apps and you have
twitter in a recent it'll be right there
so that's if i want to go
left and yeah if i want to see that yeah
you can't do that
yeah it's um it's insanely
addictive and uh if you can control
yourself
it's not that big a deal but how many
people can control themselves well i
think
the the the thing we have to hone in on
is the asymmetry of power
um you know as i say in the film it's
like we're bringing this ancient brain
hardware the prefrontal cortex which is
like what you use to do
um goal directed action self-control
willpower holding back you know
marshmallow test don't do
the don't get the marshmallow now wait
later for the two marshmallows later
all of that is through our prefrontal
cortex and when you're sitting there
and you think okay i'm gonna go watch
i'm gonna look at this one thing on
facebook because my friend invited me to
this event or it's this one post i have
to look at
and then next thing you know you find
yourself scrolling through the thing for
like an hour
right and you say man that was on me i
should have had more self-control
but there behind the screen behind that
glass slab
is like a supercomputer pointed at your
brain
that is predicting the perfect thing to
show you
next and you can feel it like it's this
is really important so like
if i'm facebook and when you flick your
finger you think
um when you're using facebook it's just
going to show me the next thing that my
friend said
but it's not doing that it when you
flick your finger it actually literally
wakes up this sort of super computer
avatar voodoo doll
version of joe and the voodoo doll of
joe
is um you know the more clicks you ever
made on facebook is like adding the
little hair
to the voodoo doll and the more likes
you've ever made
adds little clothing to the voodoo doll
and the more
um you know watch time on videos you've
ever had adds little
um you know shoes to the voodoo doll so
the voodoo doll is getting more and more
accurate
the more things you click on this is in
the film the social dilemma like if you
notice like
the character you know as he's using
this thing
uh it builds a more and more accurate
model that the ais the three ais behind
the screen are kind of manipulating
and the idea is it can actually predict
and prick the voodoo doll with this
video or that post from your friends
or this other thing and it'll figure out
the right thing to show you
that it knows will keep you there
because it's already
seen how that same video or that same
post has kept 200 million other voodoo
dolls there
because you just look like another
voodoo doll so here's an example
and this works the same on all the
platforms if you are were a teen girl
and you opened a dieting video on
youtube um
70 of youtube's watch time comes from
the recommendations on the right-hand
side
right so the things that are showing
recommended videos next
and it will uh show you it'll show
what did it show that the the girls who
watch the teen dieting video
it showed anorexia videos because those
were better
at keeping the teen girls attention not
because it said these are good for them
these are helpful for them it just says
these tend to work
at keeping their attention so again
these tend to work if you are already
watching diet videos yeah so if you're a
13 year old girl and you watch a diet
video
youtube wakes up it's voodoo doll
version of that girl and says hey i've
got like
100 million other voodoo dolls of 13
year old girls right
and they all tend to watch these these
other videos i don't know i just know
that they have this word thin spo
the inspiration is the name for it to be
inspired for anorexia yeah it's a real
thing
um youtube addressed this problem a
couple years ago but when you let the
machine run blind all it's doing is
picking stuff that's engaging
why did they choose to not let the
machine run blind with
one thing like anorexia well so now
we're getting into the twitter
censorship conversation and the
moderation conversation so the real
this is why i don't focus on censorship
in moderation because the real issue
is if you blur your eyes and zoom way
out and say how does the whole machine
tend to operate like no matter what i
start with what is it going to recommend
next
so um you know if you started with
um you know a world war ii video youtube
would recommend
a bunch of holocaust denial videos right
if you started
teen girls with a dieting video it would
recommend these anorexia videos
uh in facebook's case if you joined
there's so many different examples here
because facebook recommends groups to
people
based on what it thinks is most engaging
for you so if you were a new mom
you had renee diresta my friend on this
podcast we've done a bunch of work
together and she has this great example
of as a new mom
she joined one facebook group for
mothers who do do it yourself baby food
like organic baby food
and then facebook has this sidebar it
says here's some other groups you might
recommend
you might want to join and what do you
think was the most engaging of those
because facebook again is picking on
which group if i got you to join it
would cause you to spend the most
time here right so force some
do-it-yourself baby food groups which
group do you think
it selected probably something about
vaccines exactly so anti-vaccines for
moms yeah
okay so then if you join that group now
it does the same run the process again
so then so now look at facebook so it
says hey i've got these voodoo dolls
i've got like 100 million voodoo dolls
and they're all they just join this
anti-vaccine moms group and then what do
they tend to engage with for very long
time
if i get them to join these other groups
which of those other groups would show
up
i don't know chemtrails oh the pizzagate
flat earth flat earth absolutely yep and
youtube recommended so i'm
interchangeably going from youtube to
facebook because it's the same dynamic
they're competing for attention and
youtube recommended flat earth
conspiracy theories
hundreds of millions of times and so
when you when you're a parent during
covid
and you sit your kids in front of
youtube because you're like i'm
i've got a this is the digital pacifier
got to let them do their thing i got to
do work
right and then you come back to the
dinner table and your kid says you know
the holocaust didn't happen and the
earth is flat
and people are wondering why it's
because of this
and now to your point about this sort of
moderation thing
we can take the whack-a-mole stick after
the public yells and renee and i you
know make a bunch of noise or something
in a large community by the way of
people making noise about this
and they'll say okay shoot you're right
flat earth we got to deal with that and
so they'll tweak the algorithm and then
people make a bunch of noise about the
inspiration videos for
uh anorexia for kids and they'll deal
with that problem
but then they start doing it based
reactively but again if you zoom out
it's just still recommending stuff
that's kind of from the crazy town
section is the problem the
recommendation
because i i don't mind
that people have ridiculous ideas about
hollow earth because i think it's
humorous
but i'm also a 53 year old man right
right i'm not
i'm not a 12 year old boy with a limited
education
that is like oh my god the government's
lying to us there's lizard people that
live under the earth
right but if that's the real argument
about these conspiracy theories is that
they can influence young people or the
easily impressionable or
or people that maybe don't have a
sophisticated sense of
vetting out [ __ ] right well and the
algorithms aren't making a distinction
between
who is just laughing at it right and who
is deeply vulnerable to it and generally
it's just
it just says who's vulnerable to it
another example the way i think about
this is if you're driving down the
highway
and and you know there's facebook and
google trying to figure out like what
should i give you based on what tends to
keep your attention
if you look at a car crash and everybody
driving the highway they look at the car
crash
according to facebook and google's like
the whole world wants car crashes we
just
feed them car crashes after car crashes
after car crashes and what the
algorithms do as
guillaume chaslow in the film says who's
the youtube
whistleblower from the youtube
recommendation system is they find the
perfect little rabbit hole for you that
it knows will keep you there for five
hours
and the conspiracy theory like dark
corners of youtube
were the dark corners that tends to keep
people there for five hours
and so you have to realize that we're
now something like 10 years in
to this vast psychology experiment where
it's been
you know in every language in hundreds
of countries right and ever in hundreds
of languages
it's been steering people towards the
crazy town when i say crazytown i think
of
you know imagine there's a spectrum on
youtube and there's on one side you have
like
the calm walter cronkite carl sagan you
know
slow you know kind of boring but like
educational material or something
and the other side of the spectrum you
have you know the craziest stuff you can
find
um crazy town no matter where you start
you could start in walter cronkite or
you could start in crazytown
but if i'm youtube and i want you to
watch more am i going to steer you
towards the calm stuff or am i going to
steer you more towards crazy town
crazy dumb always more towards crazy
town so then you imagine just tilting
the floor of humanity
just by like three degrees right and
then you just
step back and you let society run its
course as jaren lanier says in the film
if you just tilt society by one degree
two degrees
that's the whole world that's that's
what everyone is thinking and believing
and so if you look at the at the degree
to which people
are deep into rabbit hole conspiracy
thinking right now and again i want to
acknowledge cointelpro
operation mockingbird like there's a lot
of real stuff right so
i'm not categorically dismissing it but
we're asking what is the
basis upon which we're believing the
things we are about the world
and increasingly that's that's based on
technology and we can get into
you know what's going on in portland
well the only way i know that is i'm
looking at my social media feed and
according to that it looks like the
entire city is on fire and it's a war
zone
but if you i called a friend there the
other day and he said it's a beautiful
day there's there's actually no violence
anywhere near where i am it's just like
these two blocks or something like that
and and this is the thing is warping our
view of reality
and and i think that's what really for
me the social dilemmas was really trying
to accomplish as a film
and you know the director jeff werlowski
was trying to accomplish is
is how did this society get go crazy
everywhere all at once
you know seemingly you know this didn't
happen by accident happened by design of
this business model
when did the business model get
implemented like when did they start
using these algorithms to recommend
things because initially
youtube was just a series of videos and
it didn't have that
recommended correct section when was
that you know it's a good question i
mean
um you know they originally youtube was
just
post a video and you can get people to
you know go to that url and send it
around
uh they needed to figure out once the
competition for attention got more
intense
they needed to figure out how am i gonna
keep you there and so recommending those
videos on the right hand side i think
that was there pretty early
if i remember actually because that's
that was sort of the innovation is like
keeping people within this youtube
wormhole
and once people were in the youtube
wormhole constantly seeing videos
that was what they could they could
offer the promise to a new video
uploader hey if you post it here you're
going to get way more views than if you
posted on vimeo
right and that's that's the thing if i
open up tik tok right now on my phone do
you have tic tac on your phone
um well i'm not supposed to obviously
but more for research purposes
do you know how to take talk at all no
okay my 12 year old is obsessed oh
really
oh yeah she can't even sit around if
she's standing still for
five minutes she just starts like
she starts tick-tocking and that's the
thing i mean 2012 2012 oh so the mayans
were right
right 2012 the platform announced an
update
to the discovery system uh designed to
identify the videos people actually want
to watch by prioritizing videos that
hold attention throughout
as well as increasing the amount of time
a user spends on the platform overall
utoh
youtube could assure advertisers that it
was providing a valuable
high quality experience for people yeah
so
um that that's beginning of the end yeah
so 2012 on youtube's
timeline i mean um you know the
twitter and facebook world i think
introduces the retweet and reshare
buttons in the 2009 to 2010 kind of time
period
so you end up with this world where the
things that we're most paying attention
to
are based on algorithms choosing for us
and so
the sort of deeper argument that's in
the film that i'm not sure everyone
picks up on is these technology systems
have taken control of
human choice they've taken control of
humanity because they're controlling the
information
that all of us are getting right think
about every election like
um i think of facebook as kind of a
voting machine but it's a
sort of indirect voting machine because
it controls the information for four
years that your entire society is
getting
and then everyone votes based on that
information now you could say well hold
on
radio and television were there and were
partisan before that
but actually tv um radio and tv are
often
getting their news stories from twitter
and twitter is
recommending things based on these
algorithms so when you control the
information that an entire population is
getting you're controlling
their choices i mean literally in
military theory if i want to screw up
your military i want to control the
information that it's getting i want to
confuse
the enemy and that information funnel is
the very thing that's been corrupted and
it's like the flint water supply for our
minds
i was talking to a friend yesterday and
she was saying that
there were articles that uh she was
laughing that there's articles that are
written
about negative tweets that random people
make
about a celebrity doing this or that and
she was like
and she was quoting this article she's
like look how crazy this is this is a
whole article
that's written about someone who decided
to say something negative about some
something some celebrity had done and
then it becomes this huge art and then
the tweets are prominently featured
right and then the response to those i
mean like like really
like arbitrary like weird because it's a
values-blind system that just cares
about what will get attention
exactly and that's what the article was
it was just an attention grab
it's interesting because um prince harry
and megan have
become very interested in these issues
and are actually working on these issues
and
um getting to know them just a little
bit are they really
yeah well they're because it affects
them personally well it's actually
interesting
i mean i don't want to speak for them
but um i think megan has been the target
of the most vitriol hate oriented stuff
on the planet right from
just the amount of sort of criticism
that they that they get really and
scrutiny yeah
i mean she's just like news feeds filled
with hate about just what she looks like
what she says just constantly
boy i'm out of the loop i've never seen
anything she's pretty
what do they think she looks like i
honestly i don't follow it myself
because i don't fall into these
attention traps i try not to but
people she just faces the worst victory
i mean this is the thing with teen
bullying right so
i think they work on these issues
because teenagers are now getting a
micro version of this thing where each
of us are scrutinized
you know and i think that's what's not i
mean think about what celebrity status
does and how it screws up humans in
general right like take an average
celebrity like it
warps your mind it warps your psychology
and you get scrutiny right
when you suddenly are followed each
person gets thousands or project forward
in the future a few years
each of us have you know tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
people that are following what we say
that's a lot of feedback and you know as
jonathan heights says in the film and i
know you've had him here yeah
you know it's made kids much more
cautious and and
less risk-taking and um and more bullied
overall and
um there's just huge problems in mental
health around this yeah it's really bad
for young girls right
um especially for celebrities and i've
had quite a few celebrities in here and
we've discussed it i just tell them that
you can't
read that stuff just don't read it yeah
like there's no good in it like i had a
friend um
she did a show she's a comedian she did
a show and she was talking about this
one negative comment
that was inaccurate you know that said
she only did a half an hour and her show
sucked she's like [ __ ] her that's not
like
i go why are you reading that she's like
because it's mostly positive i go but
how come you're not talking about most
of it then
we're talking about this one person yeah
it's one negative person we're both
laughing about it like she's
she's healthy you know she's not she's
not completely [ __ ] up by it but
this one person got into her head i'm
like i'm telling you it's not the juice
is not worth the squeeze
but don't read those things but this is
this is exactly right and this is based
on how our minds work i mean our minds
literally have something called
negativity bias so if you have a hundred
comments
and 99 are positive and one is negative
just
where does the average human's mind go
right they go to the negative
yeah and it also goes to the negative
even when you shut down the screen your
mind is sitting there
looping on that negative comment and why
because evolutionarily
it's really important that we look at
social approval negative social approval
because our reputation
is at stake in the tribe yes so it
matters yes but it's never been
easier now for not just that that one
comment to sort of gain more airtime but
then for that to build a hate mob and
then to see the interconnected clicks
and i can go in and see
10 other people that responded to that
that are now yes
and so especially when you have
teenagers that are exposed to this and
you can keep going down the tree and see
all of the hate fest on you this is the
psychological environment that is the
default
way that kids are growing up now yeah i
actually faced this recently with the
film itself because
actually the film has gotten just crazy
positive acclaim
for the most part and there's just a few
you know negative comments and for
myself even right becomes a conjunction
but i was glued to a few negative
comments and i and then you could click
and you would see
the other people that you know who
positively like or
respond to those comments like why did
that person say that negative thing i
thought we were friends that whole kind
of
psychology and we're all vulnerable to
it unless you learn as
you said to tell your celebrity friends
just don't pay attention even mild stuff
i see people fixate on even mild
disagreement or mild criticism people
fixate on
and it's um it's it's also a problem
because you realize that someone's
saying this and you're not there and you
can't defend yourself so you have this
feeling of helplessness like hey that's
not true
i didn't and then you you don't get it
out of your system
you never you never get to express it
and people can share that
false negative stuff i mean not all
negative stuff is false but you can
assert things and build on the hate fest
right and start
going crazy and saying this person's a
white supremacist or this person's even
worse
and that'll spread to thousands and
thousands of people and next thing you
know you check into your feed again at
you know
8 p.m that night and you your whole
reputation's been destroyed yes and you
didn't even know what happened to you
well and this happened to teenagers too
i mean they're anxious like i'll post
you know teenager opposed to photo
uh their high school they make a dumb
comment without thinking about it
and then next thing they know you know
at the end of the day the parents are
all calling because like 300 parents saw
it
and are calling up the parent of that
kid and it
it's you know we talk to teachers a lot
in our work at the center for humane
technology and they
um will say that on monday morning this
is before kobe but on monday morning
they spend the first like
hour of class having to clear all the
drama that happened on social media from
the weekend
for the kids jesus and
again like this and these kids are in
what age group
this is like eighth ninth ninth tenth
grade that kind of thing
and the the other problem with these
kids is there's not like uh
a long history of people growing up
through this kind of influence and
successfully navigating it yeah
these are the these are the pioneers
yeah and they won't know anything
different which is why you know we talk
about in the film like
this they're growing up in this
environment
and you know one of the simplest
principles of ethics um
uh is the ethics of symmetry doing onto
others as you would do to yourself and
as we say at the end of the film like
one of the easiest ways you know that
there's a problem here is that
many of the executives at the social
media tech companies
don't let their own kids use social
media right they literally say at the
end of the film like it's
we have a rule about it we're religious
about it we don't do it the ceo of
lunchable's foods
didn't let his own kids eat lunchables
that's when you know if you talk to a
doctor or a lawyer a doctor and you say
you know would you get this surgery for
your own kids oh no i would never do
that like would you trust that doctor
right and it's the same thing for a
lawyer so this is the relationship where
we have a relationship of asymmetry and
technology is influencing all of us
and we need a system by which you know
when i was growing up
uh you know i grew up on the macintosh
and technology and i was
creatively doing programming projects
and whatever else the people who built
the technology i was using would have
their own kits
use the things that i was using because
they were creative and they were about
tools and empowerment
and that's what's changed we don't have
that anymore because the business model
took
over and so instead of having just tools
sitting there like hammers waiting to be
used to build
you know creative projects or
programming to invent things or paint
brushes or whatever
we now have a manipulation based
technology environment where everything
you use has this
incentive to not only addict you but to
have you play the fame lottery get
social feedback because those are all
the things
that keep people's attention isn't this
also a problem with
these information technologies being
attached to corporations that have this
philosophy of unlimited growth
yes so they're they're no matter how
much they make
i i applaud apple because i think
they're the only company that takes
steps to
protect privacy to uh block
advertisements to make sure that
at least like when you when you use
their maps application they're not
saving your data and sending it to
everybody and
it's one of the reasons why apple maps
is really not as good
as google maps right but i use it
and that's one of the reasons why i use
it and when apple came out recently
and there was um they were doing
something to
uh to to block your
uh information being uh sent
to other places and they i forget what
was the exact
thing that it was in the new ios they
released a thing that blocks the
tracking identifiers
that's right and it's not actually out
yet it's going to be out in january or
february i think someone told me and
what that's due that's a good example of
they're putting a tax on the advertising
industry
because just by saying you can't track
people individually that
you know takes down the value of an
advertisement by like
30 or something here it is pops up and
you when i do safari
i get this whole privacy report thing
right that says it's like in the last
seven days it's
prevented 125 trackers from profiling me
right yeah and you can opt out of that
if you'd like if you're like no [ __ ]
that track me
yeah yeah you can do that you can let
them send your data but
that that seems to me a much more
ethical approach
to be able to decide whether or not
these companies get your information
i mean those things are great um the
challenge is imagine you get the privacy
equation perfectly right look at this
apple working on its own search engine
as google ties
could be cut soon i started using
duckduckgo
yep for that very reason just because
it's they don't do anything with it
you know they give you the information
but they don't they don't take your data
and and do anything with it the the
challenge is let's say we get all the
privacy stuff
perfectly perfectly right and data
production and data controls and all
that stuff in a
system that's still based on attention
and grabbing attention and harvesting
and strip mining
our brains uh you still get
maximum polarization addiction mental
health problems isolation teen
depression and suicide
um polarization breakdown of truth right
right so that's
we really focus in our work uh on those
topics because that's the direct
influence of the business model on
warping society like we need to name
this mind warp we think of it like the
climate change of culture
that you know we they seem like they
seem like different
disconnected topics much like with
climate change you'd say like okay we've
got species loss in the amazon we've got
we're losing insects we've got melting
glaciers we've got
ocean acidification we've got the coral
reefs you know
getting dying these can feel like
disconnected things
until you have a unified model of how
emissions change all those
different phenomena right in the social
fabric we have shortening of attention
spans
we have more outrage driven news media
we have more polarization
um we have more breakdown of truth we
have more conspiracy-minded thinking
these seem like separate events uh and
separate phenomena but they're actually
all part of this attention extraction
paradigm
that the company's growth as you said
depends on extracting more of our
attention which means more polarization
more extreme material
more conspiracy thinking and shortening
attention spans because
we we also say like you know if we want
to double the size of the attention
economy
i want your attention joe to be split
into two separate streams
like i want you watching the tv uh the
tablet and the phone at the same time
because now i've tripled the size of the
amount of extractable attention that i
can get for advertisers
which means that by fracking for
attention and splitting you into
more junk you know attention that's like
thinner
we can sell that as if it's real
attention like the financial crisis
where you're selling
thinner and thinner financial assets as
if it's real but it's really just a junk
asset
oh wow and that's kind of where we are
now where it's sort of the junk
attention economy
because we we're we can shorten
attention spans and we're debasing the
substrate
of that makes up our society because
everything in a democracy depends on
individual
sense making and meaningful choice
meaningful free will meaningful
independent views but if that's all
basically sold to the highest bidder
that debases the soil
from which independent views grow
because all of us are jacked into this
sort of matrix of social media
manipulation
that's that's ruining and degrading our
democracy and that's really
there's many other things that are
ruining integrating our democracy but
that's that's the sort of invisible
force that's upstream
that affects every other thing
downstream because if we can't agree on
what's true for example
you can't solve any problem i think
that's what you talked about in your
10-minute thing on the social dilemma i
think i saw on youtube
yeah um your organization highlights all
these issues
in you know in an amazing way and it's
very important
but do you have any solutions
it's hard right so i just want to say
that this is as a complex a problem
as climate change um in the sense that
you need to change the business model i
think of it like we're on the fossil
fuel economy and we have to switch to
some kind of
beyond that thing right because so long
as the business models of these
companies depend
on extracting attention can you expect
them to do something different like
you can't but how could you is it i mean
there's so much money involved and now
they've accumulated so much wealth that
they have
an amazing amount of influence yeah you
know and
and the asymmetric influence can buy
lobbyists can influence congress and
prevent things from happening so this is
why it's kind of the last missiles
that's right but you know i think we're
seeing signs of real change we have the
anti-trust case that was just filed
against google in congress we're seeing
more hearings
what was the basis of that case you know
to be honest i
was actually in the middle of uh the
social dilemma launch when i think that
happened and our
my home burned down in the recent fires
in santa rosa so i actually missed
that happening it's hard to hear that
yeah sorry that was a big thing to drop
but yeah no it's
it's awful there's so much that's been
happening in the last six years i've
been uh i was evacuated three times
where i lived in california oh really
yeah so we
got real close to our house justice
departments who's monopolist
google for violating antitrust laws
department files complain against google
to restore
competition and search and search
advertising markets
okay so it's all about search yeah this
is right this was a case that's about
google
using its dominant position to privilege
its own search engine
um in its own products and beyond
which is similar to sort of microsoft
bundling in the internet explorer
browser but
i you know this is all good progress but
really it misses the kind of fundamental
harm of like these things are warping
our society they're warping how our
minds are working and there's no
you know congressional action against
that because it's a really hard problem
to solve
i think the the reason the film for me
is so important is that
if i look at the growth rate of how fast
uh
facebook has been recommending people
into conspiracy groups and
um kind of polarizing us into separate
echo chambers which we should really
break down i think
as well for people like exactly the
mechanics of how that happens
but if you look at the growth rate of
all those harms compared to
you know how fast has congress passed
anything to deal with it like basically
not at all
they seem a little bit unsophisticated
in that regard like big big
understatement yeah yeah they are trying
to be
charitable i i want to be charitable too
and i want to make sure i call out and
there's senator mark warner blumenthal
um uh several other senators we've
talked to have been
really on top of these issues and led i
think senator warner's white paper
um on how to regulate the tech platforms
is one of the best it's from two years
ago in 2018
and rafi martina his staffer is an
amazing human being has worked very hard
on these issues
so there are some good folks but when
you look at the broad
like the hearing yesterday it's mostly
grandstanding to politicize the issue
right because you you turn it into on
the right um hey
you're censoring conservatives and on
the left it's hey you're not taking down
enough
misinformation and dealing with the hate
speech and all these kinds of things
right
and they're not actually dealing with
how would we solve this problem they're
just trying to make a political point
to win over their base now the facebook
recently banned the q and on pages
which i thought was kind of fascinating
because i'm like
well this is a weird sort of slippery
slope isn't it like
if you decide that you i mean it's it
almost seemed to me like well we'll
throw them a bone we'll get rid of q
on because it's so preposterous let's
just get rid of that
what else like if you keep going down
that rabbit hole where do you draw the
line
like where are you allowed to have jfk
conspiracy theories
are you allowed to have flat earth are
you allowed i mean i guess flat earth is
not dangerous
is that where they make the distinction
so i think their policy is evolving in
the direction of
when things are causing offline harm
when
online content is known to precede
offline harm that's when the platform
that's the standard by which platforms
are acting
what um what offline harm has been
caused by the q and on stuff do you know
um there's several incidents we
interviewed a guy on our podcast about
it um
there's some armed gunpoint type thing i
can't remember
um uh and there's there's things that
are priming people to be violent
you know um uh these are i just wanna
say these are really tricky topics right
i think what i wanna
make sure we get to though is that there
are many people manipulating the group
think that can happen in these echo
chambers because once you're in one of
these things like i studied cults
earlier in my career
and the power of cults is like they're a
vertically integrated persuasion stack
because they control
your social relationships they control
who you're hearing from and who you're
not hearing from
they give you meaning purpose and
belonging they
um they have a custom language they have
an internal way of referring to things
and social media allows you to create
this sort of decentralized cult
factory where it's easier to
grab people into an echo chamber where
they only hear from other people's views
and facebook i think even just recently
announced that they're going to be
promoting more of the facebook group
content
into feeds which means that they're
actually going to make it easier for
that kind of manipulation to happen
but did they make the distinction
between group content and
conspiracy groups like how do you how do
you
when when does group content
when does it cross a line i don't know i
mean the
the policy teams that work on this are
coming up with their own standards so
i'm not familiar with it if you think
about
you know think about how hard it is to
come up with a law at the federal level
that all states will agree to then you
imagine
facebook trying to come up with a policy
that will be universal to
all the countries that are running
facebook right well then you imagine how
you take a company that never thought
they were going to be in the position
to do that correct and then within a
decade they become the most prominent
source of news and information on the
planet earth
correct and now they have to regulate it
and you know i actually believe
zuckerberg when he says
i don't want to make these decisions i
shouldn't be in this role where my
beliefs
decide the whole world's views right he
genuinely believes that yeah
um and and to be certain of that but the
problem is he created a situation where
he is now
in that position i mean he got there
very quickly and they did it
aggressively when they went into
countries like myanmar ethiopia
uh all throughout the african continent
where they gave do you know about free
basics
no so this is the program that i think
has gotten something like 700 million
accounts onto facebook where they do a
deal with like a telecommunications
provider like at their version of 18t
in myanmar or something so when you get
your smartphone
facebook's built-in facebook's built-in
i do know about that and there's a
uh asymmetry of uh access where it's
free to access facebook
but it costs money to do the other
things so for the data plan so
you get a free facebook account facebook
is the internet basically
because it's the free thing you can do
on your phone and
then there's we know that there's fake
information that's being spread
so the data doesn't apply to facebook
use yeah i think like the cost
you know how we pay for data here like i
think you don't pay for facebook but you
do pay for
all the other things which creates an
asymmetry where of course you're going
to use facebook for most things
right so you facebook messenger yeah and
what's that
yeah yeah what's up i don't know exactly
with video because different
little faces has video calls as well in
general they do yeah i just don't know
how that works in the developing world
but there's a joke within facebook i
mean this has caused genocides right so
in myanmar which is in the film
um the rohingya muslim minority group
many
rohingya were persecuted and murdered
because of fake information
spread by the government on facebook
using their asymmetric knowledge with
fake accounts i mean even just a couple
weeks ago facebook took down
a network of i think several hundred
thousand fake accounts in myanmar
and they didn't even have at the time
more than something like four or five
people in their extended facebook
network who even spoke the language
of that country oh god so when you
realize that this is like
the i think of like the iraq war colin
powell
pottery barn rule where like you know if
you go in and you break it then you are
responsible for fixing it
this is facebook actively doing deals to
go into ethiopia to go into myanmar to
go into the philippines or whatever and
providing these solutions
and then it breaks the society
and they're now in a position where they
have to fix it there's actually a joke
within facebook that
if you want to know which countries will
be quote unquote at risk
in two years from now look at which ones
have facebook free basics
jesus and it's terrifying that they do
that and they don't have very many
people that even speak the language so
there's no way they're gonna be able to
filter it that's right and so now if you
take it back i know we were talking
outside about the congressional hearing
and jack dorsey and the questions from
the senator about
are you taking down the content from the
ayatollahs or from the chinese
xinjiang province about the uyghurs
uh you know when there's sort of speech
that leads to offline violence in these
other countries
the issue is that these platforms are
managing the information
commons for countries they don't even
speak the language of
right and if you think the conspiracy
theory sort of dark
corners crazy town of the english
internet are bad
and we've we've already taken out like
hundreds of whack-a-mole sticks and
they've hired hundreds of policy people
and hundreds of engineers to deal with
that problem you go to a country like
ethiopia
where um there's something like 90 major
there's 90 something dialects i think in
the country and
six major languages where one of them
is the dominant facebook sort of
language and then the others get
persecuted because they actually don't
have um
uh they don't have a voice on the
platform this is really important that
um
the people in myanmar
who got persecuted and murdered didn't
have to be on
facebook for the fake information spread
about them
to impact them for people to go after
them right so this is the whole i can
assert something
about this minority group that minority
group isn't on facebook
but if it manipulates the the dominant
culture to go we have to go kill them
then they can go do it and the same
thing has happened um you know in
india uh where there's videos uploaded
about
hey those muslims i think they're called
flesh killings
where they'll say that these muslims
killed this cow and
hindu um is it hinduism the the cows are
sacred
um the uh to get that right
anyway i believe you did yeah um the uh
they will post those they'll go viral on
whatsapp and say we have to go lynch
those
uh muslims because they killed our
sacred the sacred cows
and they went from something like five
of those happening per year to now
hundreds of those happening per year
because of fake news being spread
again on facebook facebook about them on
whatsapp about them
and again they don't have to be on the
platform for this to happen to them
right so this is critical that you know
imagine you and i are all let's imagine
all of your listeners
you know i don't even know how many you
have like tens of millions right and we
all listen to this conversation we say
we don't want to even use facebook and
twitter or youtube
we all still if you live in the us still
live in a country that everyone else
will vote
based on everything that they're seeing
on these platforms
if you zoom out to the global context
all of us
don't we don't use facebook in brazil
but if brazil
which uh was heavily the last election
was skewed uh
by facebook and whatsapp where something
like 87 percent of people
saw at least one of the major fake news
stories about bolsonaro and he got
elected and you have people in brazil
chanting facebook facebook when he wins
he wins and then he sets a new policy to
wipe out the amazon
all of us don't have to be on facebook
to be affected by a leader that wipes
out the amazon and accelerates climate
change timelines
because of those interconnected effects
so i you know we at the center for
immune technology are looking at this
from a global perspective
where it's not just the us election
facebook manages something like 80
elections per year
and if you think that they're doing all
the monitoring that they are for you
know english-speaking american election
most privileged society
now look at the hundreds of other
countries that they're operating in do
you think that they're devoting
the same resources to to the other
countries
this is so crazy it's like is that you
jamie
that's a weird noise you hear like a
squeaky i heard it too
yeah maybe it's me i don't think it is
just might be feedback there it is it
might be me
breathing i don't know do you have a you
have asthma i i think i had an allergy
coming oh yeah
i was like sorry um what's terrifying is
that
we're talking about from 2012 to 2020 um
youtube
implementing this program and then what
is the even the birth of facebook
what is that like 2002 or three like 74
2004.
this is such a short timeline and having
these massive
worldwide implications from the use of
these things
when you look at the future do you look
at this like a runaway train that's
headed towards a cliff
yeah i mean i think right now this thing
is a frankenstein
that it's not like even if facebook is
aware of all these problems
they don't have the staff unless they
hired like hundreds of you know tens
hundreds of thousands of people
definitely minimum
to try to address all these problems but
the paradox we're in
is that the very premise of these
services is to rely on automation
like it used to be we had
editors and journalists or at least
editors or you know people edited even
when on television saying what is
credible what is true like you know you
sat here with
you know alex jones even yesterday and
you're trying to check him on everything
he's saying right you're researching and
trying to look that stuff up you're
trying to be
doing some more responsible
communication the
the premise of these systems is that you
don't do that like the reason venture
capitalists find social media so
um uh profitable and such a good
investment
is because we generate the content for
free we are the useful idiots right
instead of paying a journalist
70 000 a year to write something
credible
we can each be convinced to share our
political views and we'll do it
knowingly for free
actually we don't really know the word
the useful idiots that's the kind of the
point and then
instead of paying an editor a hundred
thousand dollars a year to figure out
which of those things is true that we
want to promote and give
exponential reach to you have an
algorithm says hey what do people click
on the most
what people like the most and then you
realize the quality of the signals that
are going
into the information environment that
we're all sharing
is a totally different process we went
from a high quality gated process that
cost a lot of money
to this um really crappy process that
costs
no money which makes the company so
profitable and then we
fight back for territory for for values
when we raise our hands and say hey
there's a thinspiration video problem
for teenagers and anorexia
hey there's a mass conspiracy sort of
echo chamber problem over here
hey there's um you know flat earth sort
of issues
and again these get into tricky topics
because we want to
you know i i know we both believe in
free speech and we have this
feeling that um the solution to bad
speech is better you know more speech
that counters the things that are said
but in a finite attention economy we
don't have
the capacity for everyone who gets bad
speech to just
have a counter response in fact what
happens right now is that that bad
speech rabbit holes into
not only called worse and worse speech
but more extreme versions of that view
that confirms it
because once facebook knows that that
flat earth rabbit hole is good for you
at getting your attention back
it wants to give you just more and more
of that it doesn't want to say here's 20
people who disagree with that thing
right right so i think if you were to
imagine a
different system we would ask who are
the thinkers that are most
open-minded and synthesis-oriented where
they can actually steal man the other
side
actually they can do you know for this
speech here is the opposite counter
argument
they can show that they understand that
and imagine those people get lifted up
but notice that none of those people
that you and i know i mean we're both
friends with eric weinstein
and you know i think he's one of these
guys who's really good at sort of
offering
the steel manning here's the other side
of this here's the other side of that
but the people who generally do that
aren't the ones who get the tens of
millions of followers on these
surfaces it's the black and white
extreme outrage oriented thinkers and
and speakers
that get rewarded in this detention
economy and so if you look at how if i
zoom way out and say how is the entire
system behaving just like if i zoom out
and say climate you know the climate
system like how is the entire
overall system behaving it's not
producing the kind of information
environment
on which democracy can survive jesus
the thing that troubles me the most that
i clearly see you're thinking and i
agree with you
like i don't see any holes in what
you're saying like i don't know how this
plays out but it doesn't look good
and i don't see a solution
it's like if there are a thousand bison
running full steam towards a cliff and
they don't realize the cliff is there i
don't see how you pull them back
so i think of it like we're trapped in a
body
and um that's eating itself so like it's
kind of a cannibalism economy because
our economic growth right now with these
tech companies is based on eating our
own organs so we're eating our own
mental health organs we're eating the
health of our children we're eating
sorry for being so gnarly about it but
it's it's a cannibalistic system
in a system that's hurting itself or
eating itself or punching itself
if one of the neurons wakes up in the
body it's not enough to change that it's
going to keep punching itself but if
enough of the neurons wake up and say
this is stupid why would we build our
system this way
and the reason i'm so excited about the
film is that if you have 40 to 50
million
people who now recognize that we're
living in this sort of cannibalist
system in which
the economic incentive is to debase the
life support systems of your democracy
we can all wake up and say that's stupid
let's do something differently let's
actually change
the system let's use different platforms
let's fund different platforms let's
regulate and tame
the existing frankensteins and i don't
mean regulating speech
i mean really thoughtfully how do we
change the incentives
so it doesn't go to the same race to the
bottom and we have to all recognize that
we're now 10 years into this hypnosis
experiment of warping of the mind
and like you know friends with some
hypnotists like how do we snap our
fingers and get people to say
that that artifact there's an inflated
level of polarization and hatred right
now that especially
going into this election i think we all
need to be much more cautious about
what's running in our brains right now
yeah i don't think most people are
generally aware
of what's causing this polarization i
think they think it's the climate of
society
because the president and because of uh
black lives matter and the the
george floyd protests and all this jazz
but i don't think they understand that
that's exacerbated
in a fantastic way by social media and
the last 10 years of our addictions to
social media and these echo chambers
that we all exist in
yeah so i want to make sure that we're
both clear and i know
you agree with this that um
these things were already in society to
some degree right so we want to make
sure we're not
saying social media is blamed for all of
it absolutely not no no
gasoline is gasoline right exactly it's
it's lighter fluid for sparks of
polarization
it's lighter fluid for sparks of you
know more paranoid which is ironically
what everybody it was the opposite of
everybody what everybody hoped the
internet was going to be
right everybody hoped the internet was
going to be this bottomless resource of
information where everyone was going to
be educated in a way they had never
experienced before in the history of the
human race where you'd have access to
all the answers to all your questions
you you know eric weinstein
describes as the library of alexandria
in your pocket
yeah but no well and i want to be clear
so that i'm not against technology or
giving people access in fact i think a
world where everyone had a smartphone
and a google search box and wikipedia
and like a search oriented of youtube so
you can look up
health issues or how to do it yourself
fix anything
sure it would be awesome that would be
great i would love that just want to be
really clear because this is not an
anti-technology conversation
it's about again this business model
that depends on recommending stuff to
people
which just to be clear on the
polarization front um
it social media is more profitable when
it gives you your own truman show that
affirms your view of reality every time
you flick your finger right
like it that's going to be more
profitable than every time you flick
your finger i actually show you here's a
more complex nuanced picture that
disagrees with that
here's a different way to see it that
won't be nearly as successful and the
best way for people to test this
we actually recommend even after seeing
the film to do this is
um open up facebook on two phones
especially like
you know two partners or people who have
the same friends so you have the same
friends on facebook
you would think if you scroll your feeds
you'd see the same thing you're the same
people you're following
so why wouldn't you see the same thing
but if you swap phones and you actually
scroll through their feed for 10 minutes
and you scroll through mine for 10
minutes you'll find
that you'll see completely different
information
and it won't you'll also notice that it
won't feel very compelling like if you
asked yourself
my friend emily just did this with with
her husband after seeing the film
and she literally has the same friends
as her husband and she scrolled through
the feed she's like this isn't
interesting
i wouldn't come back to this right and
so we have to again realize how subtle
and and
yeah just how subtle this has been i
wonder what would happen if i scrolled
through my feed because i literally
don't use facebook
i don't use it at all i only use
instagram use instagram i i stopped
using twitter because it's like a bunch
of mental patients throwing [ __ ] at each
other
um and i uh very rarely use it i should
say
occasionally i'll check some things to
see like what the climate
is but uh of the cultural climate but
i use instagram and i facebook i used to
use
instagram to post to facebook but i kind
of stopped even doing that because just
it just seems gross yeah it's just and
it's these people in these verbose
arguments about
the politics and the economy and world
events and
just we have to ask ourselves is
is that medium constructive to solving
these problems no
just not at all and it's an attention
casino right the house always wins and
we're
you know eric you might see eric
weinstein in a thread you know
battling it out or sort of duking it out
with someone and maybe even reaching
some convergence on something but it
just whizzes by your feet and then it's
gone right and all the effort that we're
putting in to make these systems work
but then it's just all gone what do you
do
i mean i try to very minimally use
social media
overall um luckily the work is so busy
that that's
easier um i i want to say first that um
you know on the addiction fronts of
these things i
you know myself i'm very sensitive and
you know easily addicted by these things
myself and that's why
i think i notice you were saying in a
social dilemma it's email for you huh
yeah i well i you know for me if i
refresh my email and pull to refresh
like a slot machine sometimes i'll get
invited to
meet the president of such and such to
advise on regulation and sometimes i get
a
stupid newsletter from a politician i
don't care about or something right
um so i email is very addictive
um it's funny i talked to daniel
kahneman who wrote the he's like the
founder of behavioral economics he wrote
the book
thinking fast and slow if you know that
one and he said as well that email was
uh the most addictive for him and he you
know the one thing you'll find is the
people who know most about these sort of
persuasive manipulative tricks
they'll say we're not immune to them
just because we know about them
dan ariely who's another famous
persuasion behavioral economics guy
talks about flattery
and how flattery still feels good even
if i tell you i don't mean it like
i love that that sweatshirt that's an
awesome sweatshirt where'd you get it
you're just gonna [ __ ] me but that's
that's the um
it feels good to get flattery even if
you know that it's not real
right and the point being that like
again we have so much evolutionary
wiring to care about what other people
think of us
that just because you know that they're
manipulating you and the likes or
whatever
it still feels good to get those hundred
extra likes on that thing that you
posted
yeah when do the likes come about
um well let's see well actually you know
in the film
you know justin rosenstein who's the
inventor of the like button
talks about i think the first version
was something called beacon and it
arrived in 2006 i think
but then the simple like one-click like
button was like a little bit later like
2008 2009.
are you worried that it's going to be
more and more invasive i mean you think
about the problems we're dealing with
now
with facebook and twitter and instagram
all these
within the last decade or so what what
do we have to look forward to i mean is
there something on the horizon that's
going to be even more invasive
well we have to change this system
because as you said
technology is only to get it is only
going to get more immersed into our
lives and infuse into our lives not less
is technology going to get more
persuasive or less persuasive more
more is ai going to get better at
predicting our next move
or less good at predicting our next move
well it's almost like we have to
eliminate that
and i mean it would be really hard to
tell them you can't use algorithms
anymore
that depend on people's attention spans
right it would be really hard but it
seems like
the only way for the internet to be pure
correct i think of this like the
environmental movement i mean some
people have compared the film
the social dilemma to um rachel carson's
silent spring
right where that was the birth that was
the book that birthed the environmental
movement
and that was in a republican
administration the knicks administration
we actually passed we created the epa
the environmental protection agency
we went from a world where we said the
environment's something we don't pay
attention to
to we passed a bunch i forgot the laws
we passed between 1963 and 1972 over a
decade
we started caring about the environment
we created things that protected the
national parks we
and i think that's kind of what's going
on here that you know
imagine for example it is illegal to
show advertising
on youth oriented social media apps
between
12 a.m and 6 a.m because you're
basically monetizing loneliness and lack
of sleep
right like imagine that you cannot
advertise during those hours because we
say that like a national park
our children's attention between this is
a very minimal example by this would be
like
you know taking the most obvious piece
of low-hanging fruit and land it's like
let's quarantine this off and say this
is sacred
but isn't the problem like the the
environmental protection agency
it resonates with most people the idea
oh let's protect the world for our
children right
there's not a lot of people profiting
off of polluting the rivers right
but when you lose i mean over over
hunting you know certain lands or
overfishing certain fisheries and
collapsing them i mean there there are
if you have big enough corporations that
are based on an infinite growth profit
model
you know operating with less and less
you know resources to get this is a
problem we faced before
for so for sure but it's not the same
sort of scale
as 300 and x amount of millions of
people
and a vast majority of them are using
some form of social media
and also this is not something that
really resonates in a very clear
like one plus one equals two way like
the environmental
protection agency it makes sense like if
you ask people
right should you be able to throw
garbage into the ocean everyone's gonna
say no that's a terrible idea right
should you be able to make an algorithm
that shows people what they're
interested in on youtube like yeah
what's wrong with that well it's more
like sugar right because
sugar is always going to taste way
better than something else because our
evolutionary
heritage says like that's rare and so we
should pay more attention to it
this is like sugar for the fame lottery
for our attention for social approval
and so it's always going to feel good
and we need to have consciousness about
it and we haven't
banned sugar but we have created a new
conversation about what healthy
you know eating is right i mean there's
a whole new fitness movement in sort of
yoga and all these other things that
people care more about their bodies and
health than they probably ever have i
think many of us wouldn't have thought
we'd ever reach it through uh you know
get through the period of soda being at
the sort of
pinnacle popularity that is i think in
2013 or 14 was the year that water
crossed over
as being more of a successful drinking
product than soda
i think really i think that's true you
might want to look that up but
so i think we could have something like
that here we have to
i think of it this way if you want to
even get kind of weirdly
i don't know spiritual or something
about it which is we are the only
species
that could even know that we were doing
this to ourselves
right like we're the only species with
the capacity for self-awareness
to know that we have actually like roped
ourselves into this matrix
of like literally the matrix um of
of sort of undermining our own
psychological weaknesses
like a lion that somehow manipulated its
environment so that there's gazelles
everywhere
and is like overeating on gazelles
doesn't have the self-awareness to know
wait a second if we keep doing this
this is going to cause all these other
problems it can't do that because its
brain doesn't have that capacity
our brain we do have the capacity for
self-awareness we can name
negativity bias which is that if i have
100 comments and 99 are positive my
brain goes to the negative we can name
that and once we're aware of it we get
some agency back
we can name that we have a draw towards
social approval so when i see i've been
tagged in a photo i know that they're
just manipulating
my social approval we can name social
reciprocity which is when i get all
those text messages and i feel oh i have
to get back to all these people
well that's just an inbuilt bias that we
have to get back
reciprocity we have to get back to
people who do give stuff to us
the more we name our own biases like
confirmation bias we can name that
my brain is more likely to feel good
getting information that i already agree
with
that information that disagrees with me
once i know that about myself
i can get more agency back yeah and
we're the only
like species that we know of that has
the capacity to realize that we're in a
self-terminating
sort of system and we have to change
that by understanding our own weaknesses
and that we've created the system that
is undermining ourselves and i i think
the film
is doing that for a lot of people it
certainly is but i think it needs
more it's like inspiration it needs a
refresher
on a regular basis right do you feel
this massive obligation to be that guy
that is out there sort of as the the
paul revere
of uh the the technology influence
uh invasion i just see these problems
and i want them to go away yeah you know
i i didn't
i you know didn't desire and wake up to
run a social movement but
honestly right now that's what we're
trying to do um with
the center for humane technology we
realize that before
the success of the film we were actually
more focused on
working with technologists inside the
industry you know i come from silicon
valley many of my friends are
executives at the companies and we have
these inside relationships so we focused
at that level
we also worked with policymakers um and
we were trying to speak to policymakers
we weren't trying to mobilize the whole
world
against this problem but with the film
suddenly we as an organization have had
to do that
and we're frankly i wish we had i'm
speaking really honestly we i really
wish we'd had those funnels
so that people who saw the film could
have landed into you know a carefully
designed funnel where we actually
started mobilizing people to deal with
this issue because there are ways we can
do it we can pass certain laws
we have to have a new cultural sort of
set of norms about how do we want to
show up and use the system
um you know families and schools can
have whole new protocols of how we want
to do group migrations because one of
the problems
is that if a teenager says by themselves
whoa i saw the film
i'm going to delete my instagram account
by myself or tiktok account by myself
that's not enough because all their
friends are still using instagram and
tiktok and they're still going to talk
about who's dating who or gossip about
this or
homework or whatever on those services
and so the services instagram and tick
tock prey on social exclusion
that you will feel excluded if you don't
participate
and the way to solve that is to get
whole schools or families together like
put different parent groups or whatever
together
and do a group migration from instagram
to
signal or imessage or some kind of group
thread that way
because notice that when you as you said
apple's a pretty good actor in this
space
if i make a facetime call to you
facetime isn't trying to monetize my
attention
right it's just sitting there being like
yet when how can i help you have a good
face it's close to face-to-face
you know conversation is possible jamie
pulled up an article earlier that was
saying that uh
apple was creating its own search engine
yeah uh
i hope that is the case and i i hope
that if it is the case they apply the
same sort of ethics that they have
towards sharing your information that
they do uh
with other things to to their search
engine but i wonder
if there would be some sort of value in
them creating
a social media platform that doesn't
rely on that sort of algorithm yep
well i think in general one of the
exciting trends
that has happened since the film is
there's actually many more people
trying to build alternatives social
media products that are not based on
these business models yeah
um uh i could name a few but i i don't
want to be endorsing it i mean there's
people building marco polo clubhouse
wikipedia is trying to build a sort of
for a non-profit
version um i always forget the names of
these things but
okay but the the interesting thing is
that for the first time people
are trying to build something else
because now there's enough
people who feel disgusted by the present
state of affairs and that wouldn't be
possible unless we created a kind of a
cultural movement
based on something like the film that
reaches a lot of people it's interesting
that you made this comparison to the
environmental protection agency because
there's kind of a parallel
in the way other countries handled the
environment versus the way we do and how
it makes them competitive i mean that's
always been the republican
argument for um not getting rid of
certain fossil fuels and coal and
all sorts of things that have a negative
consequence
we we need to be competitive with china
we need to be competitive with these
other countries that don't have these
regulations in effect
the concern would be well first of all
the problem is these companies are
global right like facebook is global
if they put these regulations on america
but didn't put these regulations
worldwide then
wouldn't they use the uh the income
and the algorithm in other countries
unchecked
right and have this negative consequence
and
gather up all this money which is why
just like sugar it's like everyone
around the world has to understand and
be more antagonistic
yeah and not like sugar's evil but just
you have to have a common awareness
about the problem but how could you
educate people that
like if you're talking about some a
country like myanmar or
these other countries that that have had
these like serious consequences because
of facebook
how how could you possibly get
our ideas across to them if we don't
even know their language and it's just
this system that's already set up in
this very advantageous
way for them where facebook comes on
their phone
like how could you hit the brakes on
that well
i mean first i just want to say this is
an incredibly hard and depressing
problem yeah
just the scale of it right right um you
need something like a global i mean
language independent global
self-awareness about this problem now
again i don't want to be tweeting the
horn about the film but the thing i'm
excited about is
it launched on netflix in 190 countries
and in 30 languages so you shouldn't
the horn
[Laughter]
well i think you know the film was seen
in 30 languages so
you know the cool thing is i wish i
could show the world my inbox i think
people see the film
and they feel like oh my god this is
huge and i'm
a huge problem and i'm all alone how are
we ever going to fix this
but i get emails every day from
indonesia
chile argentina brazil people saying oh
my god this is exactly what's going on
in my country i mean i've
never felt more optimistic and i felt
really pessimistic for the last eight
years working on this because
there really hasn't been enough movement
but i think for the first time there's a
global awareness now that we could then
start to mobilize i know the eu's
mobilizing canada is mobilizing
australia's mobilizing
california state is mobilizing with prop
24 there's a whole bunch of
movement now in the space and they have
a new rhetorical arsenal
of you know why we have to make this
bigger transition
now you know are we going to get all the
the countries that
you know where there's the six different
major dialects in in ethiopia
where they're going to know about this i
don't think the film was translated into
all those dialects
i think we need to do more um it's it's
a really really
hard messy problem but on the topic of
um
uh if if we don't do it someone else
will
you know one interesting thing in the
environmental movement was
um there's a great um wnyc
radio piece about the history of lead
and when we regulated lead i don't do
you know anything about this
yeah i do yeah yeah the cruises matches
up with with your experience
the my understanding is that obviously
lead was this sort of miracle thing we
put it in paint we put it in gas
it was like great and then um the way we
figured out that we should regulate
lead out of our sort of infused product
supply
is by proving there was this this guy
who proved that it dropped kids iq by
four points for every i think
mike uh microgram per deciliter i think
in other words
for for the amount of if you had a
microgram of lead per deciliter of
either i'm guessing air um it would drop
like the iq of kids by four points
and they measured this by actually doing
a sample on their teeth or something
because lead shows up in your bones i
think
and they proved that if the iq points
dropped by four points
it would lower future age warning age
earning
excuse me wage earning potential of
those kids which would then lower the
gdp of the country
because it would be shifting the iq of
the entire country down
by four points if not more based on how
much lead is in the environment
if you zoom out and say is social media
now let's replace the word iq
which is also a wrought term because
there's like a whole bunch of views
about how that's
designed in certain ways and not others
and measuring intelligence
let's replace iq with problem solving
capacity
what is your problem solving capacity
which is actually how they talk about it
in this radio episode
um and imagine that we have a societal
iq or a societal problem-solving
capacity the u.s has a societal iq
russia has a societal iq germany has a
societal iq
how good is a country at solving its
problems
now imagine that what does social media
do to our societal iq
what distorts our ideas it gives us a
bunch of false narratives
it fills us with misinformation it makes
it impossible to agree with each other
and in a democracy if you don't agree
with each other and you can't even do
compromise people recognize that
politics is invented to avoid warfare
right
so we have compromise and understanding
so that we don't
like physically are violent with each
other we have compromise and
conversation
if social media makes compromise
conversation and undershared
understanding and shared truth
impossible it doesn't drop our societal
iq by four points it drops it to zero
because you can't solve any problem
whether it's human trafficking
or poverty or climate issues or
um you know racial injustice whatever it
is that you care about
it depends on us having some shared view
about what we agree on
and by the way and on the optimistic
side there are countries like taiwan
that have actually built a digital
democratic sort of social media
type thing audrey tang you should have
audrey tang on your show she's amazing
she's the digital minister of taiwan
and they've actually built a system that
rewards unlikely consensus so when two
people who would traditionally disagree
post something online um and when
when they actually two people who
traditionally disagree actually agree on
something that's what gets boosted to
the top
of the way that we look at our
information feeds really
yeah so it's about finding consensus
whether it'd be unlikely
and saying hey actually you know you joe
and tristan you typically you agree you
disagree on these six things
you agree on these three things and of
things that we're going to encourage you
to talk about on a menu we hand you a
menu of the things you agree on
and how did they manipulate that um
honestly
we did a great interview with her on our
podcast um that people can listen to
uh i think you should have iran honestly
i would love to but what does your
podcast again tell people
it's called your undivided attention um
and with the interview is with audrey
tang is her name
uh and i think that's this is one model
of how do you have
you know sort of digital media bolted
onto the top of a democracy and have it
work
better as opposed to how do you it just
degrades into kind of nonsense and
polarization and inability to agree
that's such a unique situation too right
because
china doesn't recognize them and there's
a real threat that they're going to be
invaded by china
correct and so what's interesting about
taiwan is there's we didn't we haven't
talked about the disinformation issues
but it's under
like you said not just physical threat
from china but massive propaganda
disinformation campaigns are trying to
run there right
i'm sure and so what's amazing is that
their digital media system is good at
um dealing with these disinformation
campaigns and conspiracy theories and
other things
even in the face of a huge threat like
china but there's more binding energy
in the country because they all know
that there's a tiny island and there's a
looming threat of this big country
whereas the united states we're not this
tiny island with a looming threat
elsewhere in fact many people don't know
or don't think that there's actually
information warfare going on
um i actually think it's really
important to point out to people
that um the social media is one of our
biggest
national security risks because while
we're obsessed with protecting our
physical borders and building walls and
you know spending a trillion dollars
redoing the nuclear fleet
um we left the digital border wide open
like if russia or china tried to fly a
plane
into the united states our pentagon and
billions of dollars of defense
infrastructure from raytheon and boeing
or whatever will shoot that thing down
and it doesn't get in if they try to
come into the country they'll get
stopped by the passport control system
ideally if they try to fly if russia or
china try to fly
an information bomb into the country
instead of being met by the department
of defense they're met by a facebook
algorithm with a white glove that says
exactly which zip code you want to
target
like it's the opposite of protection so
social media makes us more vulnerable i
think of it like
if you imagine like a bank that spent
billions of dollars
um you know surrounding the bank with
physical bodyguards
right like just the buffers guys in
every single quarter you just totally
secured the bank but then you installed
on the bank a computer system
that everyone interacts with and no one
changes the default password
from like lower case password anyone can
hack in
that's what we do when we install
facebook in our society or you install
facebook
in ethiopia because if you think russia
or china you know or
iran or south korea or excuse me north
korea um
influencing our election is bad just
keep in mind the like dozens of
countries
throughout africa where we actually know
recently there was a huge campaign
that the stanford cyber policy center
did a report on of russia targeting i
think something like seven or eight
major countries and disinformation
campaigns running in those countries
or the facebook whistleblower who came
out about a month ago uh sophie zhang i
think is her name
uh saying that she personally had to
step in to deal with
disinformation campaigns in honduras
azerbaijan
um i think greece or some other
countries like that so the scale of what
these
technology companies are managing
they're managing the information
environments for all these
these countries but they don't have the
resources to do it so they
not only that they're not trained to do
it they're not qualified correct they're
making up as they go along
20 to 30 to four and they're way behind
the curve when when i had
rene de rest on and she detailed all the
issues with the uh
internet research agency in russia and
what they did during the 2016 campaign
for both sides i mean the idea is they
just promoted
trump but they were basically selling
the seeds
of uh just the decline of the democracy
they were trying to figure out how to
create turmoil
and they were doing it in this like very
bizarre
calculated way that it didn't seem
it was hard to see like what's the end
game here well the end game is to have
everybody fight
yeah i mean that's really what the end
game was and if i'm
you know one of our major adversaries
you know after world war ii
there was no ability to use kinetic like
nukes or something on
the bigger countries right like that's
all done so
the what's the best way to take down the
biggest
you know country you know on the planet
on the block
you use its own internal tensions
against itself this is what sun tzu
would tell you to do yeah
and that's never been easier because of
facebook
and because of these platforms being
open to do this manipulation
and if i'm looking now we're four days
away from the u.s elections or something
like that when this goes out jesus
christ
there is never we have never been more
destabilized as a country
until now i mean this is the most
disabled you probably have ever
been i would say um and polarized
um maybe people would argue the civil
war was worse but in recent history
um there is maximum incentive
for foreign actors to drive up again not
one side or the other but to drive us
into conflict so i would really
you know i think what we all need to do
is recognize how much incentive there is
to plant stories to actually have so
physical violence on the streets i think
there was just a story
wasn't we talking about this morning
that um there's some kind of truck i
think in philadelphia or dc
loaded with explosives or something like
this there's there's such an incentive
to try to
you know throw the agent provocateur
like throw the first stone throw the
first
um you know molotov cocktail throw the
first uh you know make the first
shot fired uh to drive up that conflict
and i think we have to
realize how much that may be
artificially motivated
very much so and the rene de resta
podcast that i did where she went into
depth about all the different
ways that they did it and the most
curious one being
funny memes yep that there's so many of
the memes that you read that you laughed
at
yeah well there's it was just so weird
that's
they were humorous and she said she
looked at probably a hundred thousand
memes
and the funny thing is you actually can
agree with them right like they should
you would you would laugh at them
like oh you know and they're being
constructed by foreign agents
that are doing this to try to mock
certain aspects of our society
and pit people against each other and
create a mockery
and you know back in 2016 there was no
there's very little
collaboration between our defense
industry and cia and dod and people like
that
uh and the tech platforms and the tech
platform said it's government's job to
deal with if foreign actors are doing
these things
how do you stop something like the ira
like say if they're creating memes in
particular and they're funny memes
well so one of the issues that renee
brings up and i'm just a huge fan of her
and her work
uh is as am i yeah uh is
that if i'm you know china
i i don't need to invent some fake news
story i just find someone in your
society who's already saying what i
want you to be talking about and i just
like amplify them up i take that dial
and i just turn it up to ten right so i
find your
texas secessionists and like oh texas
that would be a good thing if i'm trying
to rip the country apart so i'm going to
take those tested secessionists and the
california secessionists
and i'm just going to dial them up to
10. so those are the ones we hear from
now if you're trying to stop me in your
facebook and you're the
integrity team or something on what
grounds are you trying to stop me
because it's your own people your own
free speech
i'm just the one amplifying the one i
want to be out there
right and so that's what gets tricky
about this is i think our moral
concepts that we hold so dear of free
speech are inadequate in an attention
economy that is hackable
and it's really more about what's
getting the attention rather than what
are individuals saying or can't say
and you know again they've created this
frankenstein where they're making mostly
automated
decisions about who's looking like what
pattern behavior or coordinated and
authentic behavior here or that and
they're shutting down
people i don't know if people know this
people facebook shut down two billion
fake accounts i think this is a stat
from a year ago
they shut down two billion fake accounts
they have three billion active real
users
do you think that those two billion were
the perfect like
real you know real fake accounts and
they didn't miss any or they didn't
overwhelm and took some real accounts
down with it you know our friend brett
weinstein
he just got taken down by facebook i
think he saw that
that seemed calculated though facebook
has shut down 5.4
billion fake accounts this year and that
was in november 29th oh my god
oh my god that is insane that's so many
and so again it's the scale that these
things are operating at and that's why
you know
when brett got his thing taken down i
didn't like that but i it's not like
there's this vendetta against brett
right
oh i don't know about that that seemed
to me to be a calculated thing
because uh you know eric uh actually
tweeted about it saying that
you know you could probably find the
tweet because i retweeted it
like basically it was reviewed by a
person so you're lying
he's like this is not something that was
uh taken down by an algorithm he
believes that it was because it was
unity 2020 platform
where they're trying to bring together
conservatives and and liberals
and try to find some common ground and
create like a third party candidate that
combines
the best of both worlds i don't
understand what policy
his uni unity 2020 thing was going up
against like i have no idea he's going
against a two-party system
the idea is that it's taking away votes
from biden and then it might help trump
win
right banned him off twitter as well you
know that too they they blocked the
account or something from they
they banned the entirety they banned the
20 unity 2020 account yeah
unity yeah i mean literally unity
they're like nope no unity [ __ ] you
we want biden yeah the the political
bias on
social media is undeniable and that's
maybe the least of our concerns in the
long run
but it's a tremendous issue and it also
it
it for sure sows the seeds of discontent
and it creates more animosity and it
creates more
conflict the interesting thing is that
if i'm one of our adversaries
i see that there is this view that
people don't like the social media
platforms that i want them
to be more like let's say i'm rushing
china right and i'm currently using
facebook and twitter successfully to run
information campaigns
and then i want them i can actually
plant a story so that they end up
shutting it down and shutting down
conservatives or shutting down one side
which then forces the platforms to open
up more so that i then russia china can
keep manipulating even more i understand
yeah
so right now they
want it to be a free-for-all where
there's no moderation at all because
that allows them to get in
and they can weaponize the conversation
against itself right i don't see a way
out of this
tristan we have to all be aware of it i
mean even if we are
all aware of it it seems so pervasive
yeah well it's not just pervasive it's
like we said it's
we're 10 years into this hypnosis
experiment
this is the largest psychological
experiment we've ever run on humanity
it's insane
it is insane and it and it's also with
tools that never existed before
evolutionarily so like we would we
really are not designed
just the way these brightly lit metal
devices and glass devices
interact with your brain they're so
enthralling
right we've never had to resist anything
like this before with the things we've
had to resist is don't go to the bar
you know you have an alcohol problem
stop smoking cigarettes it'll give you
cancer
right we've never had a thing that does
so much
right you can call your mom you can text
a good friend you can
you can receive your news you can get an
amazing email about this project you're
working at
and it could suck up your time staring
at butts and the
and the infusion of the things that you
that are necessary for life like text
messaging
or like looking something up are infused
and right next to
right all of the sort of corrupt stuff
right and if you're using it to order
food and if you're using it to
get an uber and right but imagine if we
all wiped our phones of all the
extractive business model stuff and we
only had the tools
have you thought about using a light
phone yeah it's funny i
those guys just to be brought up in my
awareness more more often
um for those who don't know it's like
it's like a mini
one of the guys on the documentary is
one of the creators of it right
no i think you're thinking of tim
kendall who started
he's the guy who invented who brought in
facebook's business model of advertising
and he runs a company now called moment
that shows you
uh the number of hours you spend on
different apps and helps you use it
someone involved in the documentary was
also
a part of the light phone team no no no
not not officially no i don't think so
um but the light phone is like a
basically a thing black and white black
and white
phone things text and i think it does it
plays
music now which i was like well that's a
mistake right like that's a slippery
slope
that's the thing and we have to all be
comfortable with
losing access to things that we might
love right like oh maybe you do want to
take notes this time but you don't have
your full keyboard to do that and are
you willing to
i think the thing is one thing people
can do is to take like a digital sabbath
one day a week
off completely because at the very
imagine if if you got several hundred
million people to do that that drops the
revenue of these companies by 15
because that's one out of seven days
that you're not on the system so long as
you don't rebalance and
use it more on the other days i'm
inclined to think that apple's
their solution is really the way out of
this that
to opt out of all sharing of your
information
and uh if if they could come up with
some sort of a social media platform
that kept that as an ethic
yeah i mean it might allow us to
communicate with each other
but stop all this algorithm nonsense and
it's look if anybody has the power to do
it they have so much goddamn money
totally well and also they're like that
you know people talk about
you know the government regulating these
platforms but apple is kind of the
government that can regulate the
attention economy because
when they do this thing we talked about
earlier of um saying do you want to be
tracked
right and they give you this option when
like 99 of people are gonna say no i
don't want to be tracked right when they
do that they just put a 30
tax on all the advertising-based
businesses because now you don't get as
personalized in ad
right which means they make less money
which means that business model is less
attractive to venture capitalists to
fund the next thing which means
so they're actually enacting right a
kind of a carbon tax but it's like a
uh you know on the polluting stuff right
they're enacting a kind of
um social media polluting stuff they're
taxing by 30 but they could do more than
that like imagine
you know they have this 30 70 split on
um
app developers get 70 of the revenue
when you buy stuff and apple keeps 30
percent
they could modify that percentage based
on how much sort of social
value that those things are delivering
to society
so this gets a little bit weird people
may not like this but if you think about
who's the real customer that we want to
be
like how do we want things oriented how
should we if i'm an app developer i want
to make money the more i'm helping
society and helping individuals not how
much i'm extracting and stealing their
time and attention
um and imagine that governments in the
future actually paid
um like some kind of budget into let's
say
the app store there's anti-trust issues
with this but you pay money into the app
store
and then as apps started helping people
with more social outcomes like let's say
learning programs or schools or things
like khan academy things like this
that more money flows in the direction
of where people got that value
and it was that that revenue split
between apple and the app developers
um ends up going more to things that end
up helping people as opposed to things
that were just good at capturing
attention and monetizing
uh zombie behavior one of my favorite
lines in the film is justin rosenstein
from the like button
um saying that you know so long as a
whale is worth more dead
than alive and a tree is worth more as
lumber
and two-by-fours than a living tree now
we're the whale
we're the tree we're worth more when we
have
predictable zombie-like behaviors when
we're more addicted distracted
outraged polarized and disinformed than
if we're
a living thriving citizen or a growing
child that's like playing with their
friends
and i think that that kind of
distinction that just like we protect
national parks or we protect
you know certain fisheries and we don't
kill the whales in those areas or
something
we need to really protect like we have
to call out what's sacred to us now
yeah it's um it's an excellent message
my problem that i see is that
i just don't know how well that message
is going to be absorbed on the people
that are already
in the trance i mean i think it's
so difficult for people to put things
down i mean how like i was telling you
how difficult it is to for me to tell my
friends don't read the comments
right you know right it's it's hard to
have that kind of discipline and it's
hard to have that kind of
because people do get bored and when
they get bored like if you're waiting in
line
for somewhere you pull out your phone
you're at the doctor's office you pull
out your phone
like totally i mean and that's why
you know and i do that right i mean this
is incredible right this is incredibly
hard um back in the day uh when i was at
google trying to change
i tried to change google from the inside
for two years before leaving what was it
like there
pl please share your experiences because
when you said you tried to change it
from the inside what kind of resistance
were you met with and what was their
reaction to these thoughts that you had
about the unbelievable negative
consequences of
well this is in 2013 so we didn't know
about all the negative consequences but
you saw the writing on the wall
at least some of it some of it yeah i
mean the notion that things were
competing for attention which would mean
that they would need to compete to get
more and more persuasive and hack more
and more of our vulnerabilities and that
that would grow that was the core
insight
i didn't know that it would lead to
polarization or conspiracy theory
like recommendations but i would i did
know you know more addiction
kids having less you know weaker
relationships when did it
occur to you like what were your initial
feelings um
i was on a hiking trip in the santa cruz
mountains with our co-founder now
um azeraskin um it's funny enough our
co-founder aiza
his dad was jeff raskin who invented the
macintosh project at apple i don't know
if you know the history there but
he started the macintosh project and
actually came up with the word
um humane to describe the humane
interface and that's where our name
and our work comes from is from his
father's work he and i were in the
mountains in santa cruz and just
experiencing nature
and just came back and realized like
this all of this stuff that we've built
is just distracting us
from the stuff that's really important
and that's when coming back from that
trip
um i made the first google deck that
then spread virally throughout the
company saying never before in history
have you know 50 designers uh you know
white 20 to 35 year old engineers who
look like
me to hold the collective psyche of
humanity
and then that presentation was released
and about you know 10 000 people at
google saw it it was actually the number
one
um meme within the company they have
this internal thing inside of google
called moma
that has like people can post like gifs
and memes about various topics
and it was the number one meme that hey
we need to talk about this
at this week's tgif which is the like
weekly thank god it's friday type
company meeting um it didn't get talked
about but i got
emails from across the company saying we
definitely need to do something about
this
it was just very hard to get momentum on
it and really
the the key interfaces to change within
google are chrome and android
because those are the neutral portals
into which you're then using
apps and notifications and websites and
all of that like those are the kind of
governments of the attention economy
that google runs
and when you work there did they um
did you have to use android was it part
of the the
requirement to work there no i mean a
lot of people had android phones i still
used an iphone
was it an issue no no i mean people
because they realized that they needed
products to work on on all the phones i
mean if you worked directly on android
then you would
have to use an android phone but we
tried to get you know some of those
things like
the screen time features that are now
launched you know so everyone now has on
their phone like
it shows you the number of hours or
whatever is that on android as well it
is yeah and actually that came i think
as a result of this
advocacy and that's shipping on a
billion phones which shows you you can
you can change this stuff right like
that goes against their financial
interest
people spending less time in their
phones getting less notifications it
does
but it doesn't work well correct so it
doesn't actually work is the thing
yeah and let's separate the intention
and the fact that they did it it's like
labels on cigarettes that tell you it's
going to give you cancer like by the
time you're buying them you're already
hooked
correct i mean it's even worse imagine
like um
every cigarette cigarette box had like
um a little pencil inside so you can
mark there's like little streaks that
said the number of days in a row you
haven't smoked and you could like mark
each day it's like it's too late
right right like yeah um it's just the
wrong paradigm
um the fundamental thing we have to
change is the incentives and how money
flows
because we want money flowing in the
direction of the more these things help
us
like leave me a concrete example like
let's say
um you want to learn a musical
instrument and you go to youtube to pick
up
ukulele or whatever um and you're
seeing how to play the ukulele like from
that point
in a system that was designed in a
humane and sort of time well-spent kind
of way
it would really ask you instead of
saying here's 20 more videos that are
going to just like suck you down a
rabbit hole
it would sort of be more oriented
towards what do you really need help
with
like do you need to buy ukulele here's a
link to amazon to get the ukulele are
you looking for a ukulele teacher let me
do a quick scan on your facebook or
twitter search to find out which of
those people are ukulele teachers
do you need instant like tutoring
because there's actually the service you
never heard of called skillshare or
something like that
where you can get instant ukulele
tutoring and if we're really designing
these things to be about
what would most help you next you know
we're only as good as the menu of
choices on life's menu and right now the
menu is
here's something else to addict you and
keep you hooked instead of here's a next
step that would actually be
on the trajectory of helping people live
their lives better but you'd have to
incentivize the companies because like
there's so much incentive on getting you
addicted because there's so much
financial reward
what would be the financial reward that
they could have to
get you something that would be helpful
for you like lessons or this
i mean so one way that could work is
like let's say people pay a monthly
subscription of like i don't know 20
bucks a month or something so it's never
gonna work
i get you but like let's say you pay
some you put money into a pot
where the possibility but then we have
the problem the problem is like
it costs some money versus free like
there was a um there's a company that
still exists for now
that uh was trying to do the netflix of
podcasting
and uh they they approached us and
they're like we're just gonna get all
these people together and they're gonna
make them
people gonna pay to use your podcast i'm
like why would they do that when
podcasts are free yeah like that's one
of the reasons why podcasts work is
because they're free
right when things are free they're
they're attractive
it's easy when things cost money you
have to have something that's
extraordinary
like netflix yeah like when you say the
netflix of podcasting
well netflix makes their own shows right
they spend
millions of dollars on special effects
and all these different things and
they're
really like enormous projects like
you're
you're just talking about people talking
[ __ ] and you want money right well
that's the thing is we have to actually
deliver something that's totally
qualitatively better
right and would also have to be like
someone like you
or someone who's really aware of the
issues that we're dealing with with
addictions to social media should have
to say this is this is the
best possible alternative like in this
environment
you are you yes you are paying a certain
amount of money per month
but maybe that could get factored into
your cell phone bill
and maybe with this sort of an ecosystem
right you're no longer being uh drawn in
by your addictions and you know it's not
playing for your attention span
it's rewarding you in a very productive
way and imagine
joe if like 15 more of your time
was just way better spent like he was
actually spent on you were
actually doing the things you cared
about and it actually helped improve
your life yeah like imagine when you use
email if it was truly designed
i mean forget email people don't relate
to that because email isn't that popular
but
whatever it is that's a huge time sync
for you for me email's a huge one for me
you know web browsing or whatever is a
big one imagine that those things were
so much better designed that i
actually wrote back to the right emails
and i mostly didn't think about the rest
that when i was spending time on you
know whatever i was spending time on
that it was
really my my more and more of my life
was a life well lived and time well
spent that's like the retrospective view
i keep going to apple but because i
think that the only social media comp or
excuse me the only technology company
that does have these ethics to sort of
protect privacy
have you thought about coming to them
yep have you
well i mean i i think that they've made
great first steps and they were the
first along with google to do those
the screen time management stuff but
that was just this
barely scratching the surface like baby
baby baby steps like what we really need
them to do
is radically um reimagine
how those incentives and how the phone
fundamentally works so it's not just
all these colorful icons and one of the
problems they do have a disincentive
which is a lot of the revenue comes from
gaming and as they move more into
apple tv competing with hbo and hulu and
netflix and that whole thing where they
they need subscriptions so the
apple's revenue on devices and hardware
is sort of maxing out
and where they're going to get their
next bout of revenue to keep their stock
price up
is on these subscriptions i am less
concerned with those addictions
i'm less concerned with gaming
addictions than i have information
addictions because at least it's not
fundamentally altering your view of the
world right it's screwing up democracy
and making it impossible to agree well
and this is coming from a person that's
had like legitimate
video game addictions in the past but uh
like my wife is addicted to subway
surfer
like i don't know what it is it's a
crazy game it's like you're riding on
the top of subways you jumping around
it's like
it's really ridiculous but it's fun like
you watch like whoa but i don't [ __ ]
with video games but i watch it and
it's those games at least
are enjoyable there's something silly
about it like ah
[ __ ] and then you start doing it again
when i see people getting angry about
things on social media i don't see
the upside right i don't mind them
making a profit off games
there is an issue though with games that
addict children and then these children
there's like you could spend money on
like roadblocks
and you can you know have all these
different things you spend money on you
wind up
you know you're having these enormous
bills you leave your kid with an ipad
and you come back you have a 500
bill like what did you do yeah this is
this is an issue for sure but at least
it's not an issue
in that it's changing their view of of
the world right and i i feel like
there's a way
for i keep going back to apple but a
company like apple
to rethink the way that you know they
already have a walled garden right with
imessage and
facetime and all this different i can
totally build those things out i mean
imessage in icloud could be
the basis for some new neutral social
media yeah it's not based on instant
social approval and rewards right yes
they can make it easier to share
information with small groups of friends
and have that all synced and even
you know in the pre-covet days i was
thinking about apple a lot i think
you're right by the way to really poke
on them i think they're the one company
that's in a position
to lead on this and they also have a
history of thinking along those lines
you know they had this feature that's
kind of hidden now but to find my
friends right they call it find my now
it's all buried together so you can find
your devices
and find your friends but in a
pre-coveted world imagine they really
built out
the you know where are my friends right
now and making it easier to know when
you're nearby someone
so you can easily more easily get
together in person so right now all the
like to the extent facebook wants to
bring people closer together they don't
want to and again this is pre-coveted
but
they don't want to incentivize lots and
lots of facebook events they really care
about groups that keep people posting it
online and looking at ads because
of the category of bringing people
closer together they want to do the
online screen time based version of that
right as opposed to the offline
apple by contrast if you had little
imessage groups of friends you could say
hey does everyone in this little group
want to opt into being able to see where
each other are where we all
are on say weekdays between 5 and 8 pm
or something like that so you could like
time bound it
and make it easier for serendipitous
connection and availability to happen
that's hard to do it's hard to design
that but there's things like that that
apple's in a position to do
if it really took on that mantle and i
think as people get more and more
skeptical of these other
products they're in a better and better
position to do that
one of the antitrust issues is do we
want a world where our entire well-being
as a
society depends on what one massive
corporation worth over a trillion
dollars
does or doesn't do right like we need
more
openness to try different things and
we're really at the behest of whether
one or two companies apple or google
does something more radical
and there has to be some massive
incentive for them to do something
that's really going to change
yeah the the way we interface with these
devices and the way we interface with
social media
and i don't know what incentive exists
it's more potent than financial
incentives well and this is where the
you know if the government in the same
way that we want to transition
long term uh from a fossil fuels
oriented economy to something that that
doesn't
um that changes the kind of pollution
levels
uh you know we have a hugely emitting um
you know society ruining kind of
business model of this attention
extractive paradigm
and we could long term sort of just like
a progressive tax on that
transition to some other thing the
government could do that right um
that's not like who do we censor it's
how do we disincentivize these
businesses to pay for the
sort of life support systems of society
that they've ruined a good example of
this i think in australia
is there um i think it's australia
that's regulated
that google and facebook have to pay the
publishers who they're basically
hollowing out because one of the effects
we've not talked about
is the way that google and facebook have
hollowed out the fourth estate in
journalism
i mean because journalism has turned
into in local web news websites
can't make any money except by basically
producing click bait
so even to the extent that local
newspapers exist they only exist by
basically click betification
of even lower and lower paid you know
workers who are just generating content
farms
right so anyway so that's an example of
if you force those companies to
pay to to revitalize the fourth estate
and to make sure we have a
very sustainably funded fourth estate
that doesn't have to produce this
clickbait stuff
uh that's that's you know another
direction yeah that
uh that's interesting that they have to
pay
i mean these are the wealthiest
companies in like the history of
humanity
right so that's the thing so we
shouldn't be cautious about how much
they should have to pay
except we also don't want to happen on
the other end right you don't want to
have a world where
you know we have roundup making a crazy
amount of money
from giving everybody cancer and
lymphoma from
uh you know all the chemicals right
glyphosates and then
they pay everybody on the other end
after a lawsuit of a billion dollars but
now everyone's got cancer let's actually
do it in a way
so we don't want a world where facebook
and google profit
off of the erosion of our social fabric
and then they pay us back
how do you quantify how how much money
they have to pay
to journalism yeah it seems like it's
almost
a form of socialism or yeah i mean this
is where like that
the iq led example is interesting
because they were able to
disincentivize and tax the lead
producers
because they were able to produce some
results on how much this lowered the
wage earning potentials of the entire
population i mean like how much does
this cost our society we used to say
free is the most expensive business
model we've ever created because we get
the free downgrading of
our attention spans our mental health
our kids like our ability to agree with
each other our capacity to do anything
as a democracy
like yeah we got all that for free
wonderful obviously we get lots of
benefits and i want to
acknowledge that but that's just not
sustainable the real question i mean
right now we're
we have huge existential problems we
have a global competition power
competition going on
i think china just passed the gdp of the
us i believe
there is you know if if we care about
the us
having a future in which it can lead the
world in in some meaningful and
enlightened way
we have to deal with this problem and we
have to have a world where digital
democracy
outcompetes digital authoritarianism
which is the china model
and right now that builds more coherence
and is more efficient and doesn't evolve
the way that
our current system you know does i think
taiwan
estonia and countries like that where
they are doing digital democracies are
good examples that we can learn from
but we're behind right now well china
also has a really fascinating situation
with huawei
where google is banned huawei
so you can't have google applications on
huawei so now huawei is creating their
own
operating system and they have their own
ecosystem now that they're building up
and that's you know it's it's weird that
there's only a few different operating
systems now
i mean there's a very small amount of
people using linux phones
then you have a large amount of people
using android and iphones and if china
becomes the first to
adopt their own operating system and
then they have
even more unchecked rules and
regulations in regards to like
the influence they have over their
people with an operating system that
they've developed
and they control and who knows what kind
of back doors and
spying tons yeah it's
it's weird yeah when you see this
do you like it feels
so futile for me on the outside looking
in looking
but you you're working on this how long
do you
anticipate is going to be a part of your
life i mean what does it feel like to
you
[Music]
um
i mean it's not easy right um
in the the film ends with this question
do you think we're gonna get there
yeah i just say we have to like i mean
if you care about this going well i wake
up every day and i ask
what will it take for this whole thing
to go well like
and how do we just orient each of our
choices as much as possible
towards this going well we have a whole
bunch of problems i do
look a lot at the environmental issues
the permafrost methane bombs like
the timelines that we have to deal with
certain problems are crunching and we
also have certain dangerous exponential
technologies that are emerging
decentralization of you know crispr and
like there's a lot of existential
threats i hang out with a lot with the
sort of existential threats community
it's going to take it must be a lot of
fun
it's uh there's a lot of psychological
problems in that community actually
a lot of depression there's only an
imaginary suicide as well
it's it's uh you know it's
it's hard but i i think we each have a
responsibility when you see this stuff
to say
what will it take for this to go well
and i will say that really seeing
the film impact people the way that it
has
i i used to feel like oh my god how are
we ever going to do this no one cares
like none of people know
right at the very least we now have
about 50
40 to 50 million people who are at least
introduced to the problem
the question is how do we harness them
into a collective movement and that's
what we're trying to do next i mean i
i'll say also these issues get
more and more weird over time my
co-founder is raskin will say that it's
making reality more and more virtual
over time because we haven't talked
about how
as technology advances
at hacking our weaknesses we start to
prefer it over the real thing we start
for example
there's a recent company vc funded
raised like
i think it's worth like over 125 million
dollars and what they make
are virtual influencers so these are
like virtual
people virtual video
that is more entertaining more
interesting and
that fans like more than real people oh
boy
and it's kind of related to the kind of
deep fake world right where like people
prefer this to the real thing and cheri
turkel
um you know who's been working at mit
wrote the book reclaiming conversation
and alone together she's been talking
about this forever that
over time humans will prefer connection
to
robots and bots and the computer
generated thing
more than the real thing think about ai
generated music
being more it'll start to sweeten our
taste buds and give us exactly that
thing we're looking for better than we
will know ourselves
just like youtube can give us the
perfect next video that actually every
bone in our body will say actually i
kind of do want to watch that even
though it's a machine pointed at my
brain calculating the next thing
there's an example from microsoft
writing this chat bot called
xiaoice i couldn't pronounce it that
after nine weeks people
preferred that chatbot to their real
friends and 25 or
10 10 to 25 percent of their users
actually said i love you to the chatbot
oh boy and that many there are several
who actually said that it convinced them
not to commit
suicide to have this relationship with
this chatbot so it's her
it's her it's the movie exactly which is
what so all these things are the same
right
we're veering into a direction where
technology if it's so good at meeting
these underlying
paleolithic emotions that we have
the way out of it is we have to see that
this is what's going on we have to see
and reckon with ourselves saying this is
how i work i have this negativity bias
if i get those 99 comments and one spot
one's
positive comments and one's negative my
mind is going to go to the negative i
don't see that
i see you in the future wearing an
overcoat
you're you are literally lawrence
fishburne in the matrix
trying to tell people to wake up well
that's there's a line in the social
dilemma where i say how do you wake up
from the matrix if you don't know you're
in the matrix
well that is the issue right and i even
in the matrix we at least had a shared
matrix the problem now is that in the
matrix each of us have our own matrix
that's the real kicker
i struggle with the idea that this is
all inevitable because this is a natural
course of progression with technology
and that it's sort of figuring out the
best way
to to have us with
as little resistance embed ourselves
into its system
and that our ideas are what we are
with emotions and with our biological
uh issues that this is just how life is
and this is how life always should be
but this is just all we've ever known
that's all we've ever known einstein
didn't write into the laws of physics
that social media has to exist for
humanity right right we've gotten rid
again the environmental movement is a
really interesting example because we
passed all sorts of laws we got rid of
lead we've changed
from you know some of our pesticides um
you know we're slow on some of these
things and
corporate interests and asymmetric power
of large corporations
you know which i want to say markets and
capitals are great is that when you have
asymmetric power for predatory
systems that that cause harm they're not
going to uh terminate themselves they
have to be
bound in by the public by culture by by
the state
and um we just have to point to the
examples where we've done that
and in this case i think the prob the
problem is that how much of our stock
market
is built on the back of like five
companies generating
a huge amount of wealth so this is
similar i don't mean to make this
example but um there's a great book
by um adam hokeshield
called bury the chains which is about
the british abolition of slavery
in which he talks about how for the
british empire like if you think about
it
when when we collectively wake up and
say this is an abhorrent practice that
has to end
but then at that time in the 17 1800s
in britain slavery was what powered the
entire economy it was free labor
for you know huge percentage of the
economy so if you say we can't do this
anymore we have to stop this how do you
decouple
when your entire economy is based on
slavery
right and the book is actually inspiring
because it tracks
a collective movement that was through
networked all these different groups the
quakers
uh in the u.s the uh people testifying
before parliament the former slaves who
did first-hand accounts the graphics and
art of all the
people had never seen what it looked
like on a slave ship and so by making
the invisible visceral and showing just
how abhorrent this stuff was
through a period of about 60 to 70 years
the british empire
had to drop their gdp by 2 every year
for 60 years and willing to do that
to get off of slavery now i'm not making
a moral equivalent i want to be really
clear for everybody taking
things out of context um but just that
it's possible for us to do something
that isn't just in the interest of
economic growth
and i think that's the real challenge
that's actually something that should be
on the agenda which is
how do we one of the major tensions is
economic growth
you know being in conflict with dealing
with some with many of our problems
whether it's some of the environmental
issues or
you know with some of the technology
issues we're talking about right now
artificial intelligence is something
that people are terrified of as an
existential threat they think of it as
one day you're going to turn something
on and it's going to be sentient
it's going to be able to create other
forms of artificial intelligence that
are exponentially more powerful than the
one that we created
and that will have unleashed this beast
that we cannot control
what my concern is with all this yeah
that's my concern my concern is that
this
this is a a slow
acceptance of drowning yeah that's like
a slow
we're okay i'm only up to my knees oh
it's fine
it's just uh my waist high it could be
boiling water
exactly exactly it seems like
this is like humans have to fight back
to
reclaim our autonomy and free will from
the machines i mean
one clear okay neo it's very much
the matrix and one of my favorite lines
is actually when the oracle says to neo
and don't worry about the vase and he
says what face and he knocks it over
that face and so it's like she's the ai
who sees so many moves ahead in the
chess board
she can say something which will cause
him to do the thing that verifies the
thing that she predicted what happened
yeah that's what ai is doing now except
it's pointed at
our nervous system and figuring out the
perfect thing to dangle in front of our
dopamine system
and get the thing to happen which
instead of knocking off the vases to be
outraged at the other political side and
be fully certain that you're right even
though it's just a machine that's
calculating [ __ ] that's going to make
you
you know do the thing when you're
concerned about this how much time do
you spend thinking about simulation
theory
the simulation yeah the idea that it if
not
currently one day there will be a
simulation that's indiscernible
yeah from regular reality and it seems
we're on that path i don't know if you
mess around with vr
at all but well this is the point about
you know the virtual chat bots out
competing
for exactly the technology you know i
mean that's what's happening is that
reality is getting more and more virtual
right because
we interact with a virtual news system
that's all this sort of click-bait
economy
outrage machine that's already a virtual
political environment that then
translates into real world action then
becomes real and that's the weird
feedback
go back to 1990 whatever it was when the
internet became mainstream
or at least started becoming mainstream
and then the small amount of time that
it took the 20 plus years to get to
where we are now
and then think what what about the
virtual world
and once this becomes something that's
has the same sort of rate of growth that
the internet has experienced or that
we've experienced through the internet
i mean we're looking at like 20 years
from now being unrecognizable
yeah we're looking at i mean it's it
almost seems like that
is what life does the same way bees
create bee
hives you know a caterpillar doesn't
know what the [ __ ] going on when it
gets into that cocoon but it's becoming
a butterfly
we seem to be a thing
that creates newer and better
objects correct more effective but we
have to realize
ai is not conscious and won't be
conscious the way we are and so
many people think that but is
consciousness
essential i think so to us
i don't know essentially we're the only
ones who have it no i don't know that
no theory but there might be more yeah
things that have consciousness but
is it is it essential i mean it's the to
the extent that choice
exists it would exist through some kind
of consciousness
and this choice is choice essential
it's essential to us as we know it like
as life as we know it
but my worry is that we're in essential
that
like we we're thinking now like
single-celled organisms being like hey i
don't want to
gang up with a bunch of other people and
become an object that can walk
i like being a single cell organism this
is a lot of fun i mean i hear you saying
you know are we a bootloader for the ai
that then runs
that's eli's perspective i mean i think
this is a really dangerous way to think
i mean we have to
yeah so are we then dangerous for us
yeah i mean
what if the next version of the life is
the next version being run by machines
that have no values that don't care that
don't have choice and are just
maximizing for things that were
programmed in by our little miniature
brains anyway
but they don't cry they don't commit
suicide but then consciousness and life
dies
that could be the future i think this is
the last chance to try to snap out of
that
and is it important in the eyes of the
universe that we do that i don't know it
feels important how does it feel to you
it feels important but i
i'm i'm a monkey you know the monkey's
like
i'm staying in this tree man you guys
are out of your [ __ ] mind i mean this
is the weird paradox of being human is
that again we have these lower level
emotions we care about social approval
we can't not care at the same time like
i said
there's this weird proposition here
we're the only species that if this were
to happen to us
we would have the self-awareness to even
know that it was happening
right like we can consent like this
two-hour interview we can conceptualize
that this this thing has happened to us
right that we have built this matrix
this external object which has like ai
and supercomputers and voodoo doll
versions of each of us
and it has perfectly figured out how to
predictably move each of us in this
matrix
let me propose this to you we are what
we are now
human beings homo sapiens in 2020. we we
are this thing
that uh if you believe in evolution i'm
pretty sure you do
we've evolved over the course of
millions of years to become who we are
right now
should we stop right here are we done no
right we should keep it evolving
what does that look like
what does it look like if we go ahead
just forget about social media
what would you like us to be
in a thousand years or a hundred
thousand years
or five hundred thousand years you
certainly wouldn't want us to be what we
are right now right
no one would no i mean i think this is
what visions of star trek and things
like that we're trying to ask right like
hey
let's imagine humans do make it and we
become the most enlightened we can be
and we actually somehow make peace with
these other you know alien tribes and we
figure out
you know space travel and all of that i
mean
actually a good heuristic that i think
people can ask is on an enlightened
planet where we did figure this out
what would that have looked like isn't
it always weird that those movies
it's people are just people but they're
in some weird future but they haven't
really changed that much
right i mean and which is to say that
the fundamental way that we work is
just unchanging but there are such
things as more wise societies more
sustainable societies more peaceful or
harmonious societies
ultimately biologically we have to
evolve as well
but our version of like the best version
is probably the gray aliens
right maybe so that's the ultimate
future i mean we're going to get into
gene editing and becoming more
perfect perfect on the sense of you know
that but
uh we're going to start optimizing for
what are the outcomes that we value i
think the question is how do we actually
come up with brand new values
that are wiser than we've ever thought
of before that actually are able to
transcend the win lose games that lead
to omni lose lose that everyone loses
if we keep playing the win lose game at
greater and greater scales
i like you have a vested interest in the
biological existence of human beings
i think people are pretty cool yeah i
love being around them i enjoy talking
to you today
my fear is that we are
we're we're a model t right you know and
there's there's no sense in making those
[ __ ] things anymore the brakes are
terrible
they smell like [ __ ] when you drive them
they don't go very fast
we need a better version you know the
funny thing is
god there's some quote by someone i
think like i wish i could remember it
it's
something about how much would be solved
if we were at peace with ourselves
like if we were able to just be okay
with
nothing like just being okay with living
and breathing
i don't mean to be you know playing the
woo new age card i just genuinely mean
how much of our lives is just running
away from you know anxiety and
discomfort and aversion
it is but you know in that sense some of
the most satisfied and happy people are
people that live a subsistence living
that have these subsistence existences
in the middle of nowhere just chopping
trees and
catching fish right and more connection
probably yeah authentic
than something else i think that's
probably resonates biologically
too because of the history of human
beings living like that is just
so much longer and greater totally and i
think that those are more sustainable
societies
we can never obtain peace in the outer
world until we make
peace with ourselves dalai lama yeah but
i don't buy that guy
you know that guy he's uh he's an
interesting case
i was thinking there was a different
slightly different quote but actually
there's one quote that i would love to
if it's possible one of the reasons why
i don't buy him he's just
chosen they just chose that guy yeah
also he doesn't have sex wait how
how um yeah how much can you be enjoying
life if that's not not a party come on
bro
you wear the same outfit every day the
[ __ ] out of here with your orange robes
can i there's a there's a really um
important quote that i i think would
really be good to share
uh it's from the book have you read
amusing ourselves death by neil postman
no
from 1982 no um so
especially when we get into big tech and
we talk about censorship a lot and we
talk about orwell
um he has this really wonderful opening
to this book
it was written in 1982 it literally
predicts everything that's going on now
i frankly think that
i'm adding nothing and it's really just
neil postman called it all in 1982.
uh he had this great opening it says
um let's see we're all looking out for
you know 1984 when the year came and the
prophecy didn't
thoughtful americans sang softly in
praise of themselves the roots of
liberal democracy had held
this is like we made it through the 1984
gap wherever else
the terror had happened we at least had
not been visited
by orwellian nightmares but we had
forgotten that alongside orwell's dark
vision
there was another slightly older
slightly less well-known
equally chilling vision of aldous
huxley's brave new world
contrary to common belief even among the
educated huxley and orwell did not
prophecy the same thing
orwell warns that we will become
overwhelmed overcome
by an externally imposed oppression but
in huxley's vision
no big brother is required to deprive
people of their autonomy maturity or
history
as he saw it people will come to love
their oppression
to adore the technologies that undo
their capacities to think
what orwell feared were those who would
ban books
what huxley feared was that there would
be no reason to ban a book
for there would be no one who wanted to
read one orwell feared those who would
deprive us of information
huxley feared those who would give us so
much that we would be reduced to
passivity and egoism
orwell feared the truth would be
concealed from us
huxley feared the truth would be drowned
in a sea of irrelevance
orwell feared we would become a captive
culture but huxley feared we would
become
a trivial culture preoccupied with some
equivalent of the feelis
and the orgy porgy and the centrifugal
bumble puppy don't know what that means
as huxley remarked in brave new world
revisited the civil libertarians
and rationalists who are ever on the
alert to oppose
tyranny failed to take into account
man's almost infinite appetite for
distractions
lastly in 1984 orwell added people are
all people are controlled by inflicting
pain
in brave new world they are controlled
by inflicting pleasure
in short or well feared that what we
fear will ruin us
huxley fear that what we desire will
ruin us holy [ __ ]
isn't that good that's that's the best
way to end this
god damn but again if we can become
aware
that this is what's happened we're the
only species with the capacity
to see that our own psychology our own
emotions our own paleolithic
evolutionary system
has been hijacked i like that you're
optimistic we have to be
optimism is probably the only way to
live in a meet suit body and keep going
otherwise it certainly helps yeah it
certainly helps
thank you very much for being here man i
really enjoy this even though i'm really
depressed
now i really don't want you to be
depressed i really hope people you know
i'm kidding we're not
we really want to build a movement and
and uh you know we're just
i wish i could give people more
resources we do have a podcast um called
undivided attention
and we're trying to build a movement at
humanetech.com but well listen
any new revelations or new developments
that you have i'd be more than happy to
have you on again
we'll talk about them and send them to
me and i'll put them on social media and
whatever you need
awesome i'm here to help awesome man
great great to be here resist yeah
grizzly
together humanity resist humanity we're
in this together thank you tristana i
really really appreciate it
goodbye everybody
[Music]
you